Hello everybody.
Welcome back to a deadly premonition.
I have not heard this.
I have not been listening to this song actually.
I don't remember how it goes.
She was inside our coffee.
Don't say boo like that, you scared me.
You hear that, Zach?
The little Ibu got scared by a simple boo.
They are...
They are of...
They are like cavemen.
And we are the future aliens.
Or something.
What did he call them?
Like...
He definitely was just like, oh yes, we are in advance.
I am an advanced species.
Hello, Mito, and I was like, you!
First, we deadly, then we premonition.
Let's deadly premonition, Zach!
Thank you, Calvo!
Sentient beings or something.
Yeah, something, right?
Yay, more Twin Peaks the game!
Yeah!
Oh, cavemen.
Wait, I can't remember what he called them.
First time we've caught your stream live.
Hello!
Thanks for being here.
Thank you, thank you.
I am 100% okay with you meandering with side quests in this
game.
Everything about the dialogue scenes are pure gold.
100%.
Thank you, Grim.
Thank you.
Meanderthals.
We're going way back.
Good morning, Minto!
Got a day off work for annoying reasons.
So I can actually see what this game looks like instead of
just hearing your reactions.
I'm sad it's for annoying reasons.
Meanderthals.
Me?
You?
No.
Nah.
I'm Minto.
I'm terrified.
Sometimes the soundtrack comes on when I'm thinking.
I'm not relating to York, right?
You might have a Zach in your head.
Mi gongaga.
Mi gong gong gong.
I hope you guys listen to your daily mi gong gong gaga,
yeah?
Hope you're enjoying your journey through this daily
premonition, Minto.
Your silly streams are such a comfort after a long,
stressful day.
No, sorry, a long, stressful.
Long, fun.
Fun.
Long, stressful?
No.
For me though, all day today I've just been pack, pack,
packing.
I'm packing.
Yeah, baby.
I'm packing these guns.
It's been a vocal stim lately.
I'm always Gongaga.
I'm always me Gongaga.
Wait a second.
oh my gosh wait what if in the new I don't think we didn't
see Zach that much in like Advent Children the new one the
new one right I mean it makes sense but what if when he okay
I'm assuming okay I'm theorizing that he's going to come
back in the third one what if he gonkaga's everybody would
clap and cheer no we saw Zach a little bit didn't we in the
remakes in the seven remakes no it has to i would cry me too
i would point i would point leonardo decaprio style you know
what speaking of that guy i watched the great gatsby
recently i had never read the great gatsby i was never
required to as my You know, ghostly learnings, my knowledge.
And I don't know if I read it as a human.
But I watched him in the Great Gatsby.
Yeah, the movie, the movie.
And...
I didn't know Toby McGuire was in that movie, too.
I can't say if it's a good adaptation of the book, but I
liked the movie.
I got an email saying, Spooky hunting and merch arriving.
Wait, arrived!
Oh my gosh!
When I got home, it wasn't there.
I thought...
Wait, I thought someone stole it.
I got super down, then I let my dog out and he spotted in
the backyard.
The wave of relief!
Why was it in your backyard?
Fumo mint is so big.
Thanks for ordering it, Foxy!
Thank you.
Yeah.
Every stream with our minke plays, the life is beautiful
song.
Oh no.
Reading was tedious.
The Bully Maguire.
Yes, yes, yes.
And that guy is so goofy.
It's so funny.
My density debut stuff is shipping.
Yippee!
Thank you!
I kind of want to read the book, though.
I liked the movie a lot.
I did actually know the ending, though.
So maybe I did read it.
Happy birthday!
I'll sing you...
Metal Gear style.
Happy birthday, congratulations.
Happy birthday, we salutations.
Happy birthday, may your sky stay blue.
Happy birthday to you.
Woo-hoo!
Happy birthday!
And no one else just watch a 10-minute YouTube about it.
What, the Great Gatsby?
I think I had to read...
The Scarlet Letter.
I don't remember much about it.
I remember...
No spoilers for the movie or book, but they did seem to make
some cuts for the adaptation.
I see.
Did you have a favorite school book?
Actually, I think like the Odyssey.
Or like, rather like, you know, going through like spark
notes of like that kind of that's like that stuff oh the
outsiders oh my gosh i used to write fan fiction of the
outside i wrote yaoi fan fiction of the outsiders the
odyssey is great
i don't know oh it's so strange because like thinking back i
never fanfiction of like anime.
I did write fanfiction of Roxas Axel from Kingdom Hearts,
but I would write fanfiction of like books that I read.
I think that is, that might be worse than like being a
weeaboo.
Like that just sounds like the most nerdy thing to do is to
read a book and then write a fanfiction about.
I don't know.
There was like some, I don't remember, some like young teen
novel that I had read.
And like, I was upset.
I wrote in like the margins and I tabbed pages that like had
my OTP interacting and everything.
I went nuts over this book series.
And they, they canceled it.
They canceled it.
They didn't even, like they never finish the series i will
maybe that's why i am a ghost i have no
i've got no uh no conclusion have you ever considered being
a vtuber publisher in the future no i've never considered
that i don't think i could my unfinished business i still
haven't gotten the teal ghost bobo i oh yeah i mentioned the
other day but i got an orange ghost with Sea foam tips.
Good Minto perhaps blessed me with a name I did for the
little lad.
Kiwawa.
Orange ghost with sea foam tips?
That sounds like kiwawa to me.
I wrote fanfic about a book I read too.
Yeah, next year!
We are of kin.
Looking forward to Fuminto arriving soon.
My brother also grabbed me some yummy mamamintos from Ashen
this weekend.
Nice brother.
Thank you.
It makes you feel better.
About 95% of King Arthur lore is other writers' fanfic.
Really?
Fanfic about school books is next level book report.
I know!
Kiwawa the baby Bobo.
That's so cute.
I feel like, though, I definitely, if I had read The Great
Gatsby, I would have written fanfiction about it.
100% I think I would have
Lancelot is basically France's OC I love that for them It's
never too late I never published any of my fan fictions But
maybe it's time to make my first AO3 account
There's some ultra toxic powering, so oh yeah.
Start a book club?
Yeah, but it would be all like my smuddy books that are
really funny and sexy.
But like, sexy in like a not sexy way.
They're just, they talk about the sexy, but they don't feel
very sexy.
you guys can start with um oh gosh i should pick up
something i think i've been saying that i need to pick up
something soon like i should i should listen to something
but while i'm packing i can listen yeah you can start with a
minotaur milking farm and then we'll go from there
100 would subscribe to minto book club right now though i
don't like i have time to of Enzo Man City.
I missed that guy.
I submitted a Pride and Prejudice fanfiction for a creative
writing assignment in senior year of high school.
I'm in good company around here.
I said, yes you are!
As a recovering AO3 addict, I read Minto's fix.
Cover to cover.
What if I'm, like, really bad at it, though?
You don't know how I write.
I could be all over the place.
Just like how I think normally my brain is like nothing can
make sense probably I picked up the milking farm audio book
we'll listen at work soon oh good idea that's where I listen
so you know I would listen to all the books at work it's
about the passion put into the words yeah just do a
read-along
Oh my gosh, I should do my own audiobook of...
The second one is the craziest.
The Minotaur Milking Farm is fine.
It's actually a good book.
But the second one...
Hold on, what was it called?
Uh...
What was that?
Oh my gosh, I'm...
Oh, sexy, filthy boss.
She's still here.
Yes.
Oh my god, wait, is it playing?
Okay, good.
Or no.
This one here, I'll read you about this book.
It's over at T.D.
This is a book I read.
He's the sexy alpha male in the corner office who goes
through a system.
distance faster than free donuts in the break room.
I'm the assistant who has chosen to cover for his last fire.
The owner of the company is clear.
Hook the biggest client in our firm's history and there's a
partnership for him and a promotion for me.
Stipulation.
We do it together.
It doesn't take a tarot card reading psychic to figure out
where our story is late nights, trips out of town, and more
than a few awkward moments filled with sexual tension.
No worries though.
I pride myself on willpower.
I can totally ignore his sexy grin, his rock-hard body, and
his dreamy brown eyes.
I will not become the woman other women hate.
But it turns out that Enzo Mancini.
Enzo Mancini.
This is my favorite part.
Enzo Mancini has a lot of layers.
And if I don't stop peeling, I'm going to lose everything,
including my dignity.
Members only read.
along oh my god this book has this book is 10 out of 10 the
best book of in the great Gatsby that I never read it has
such prolific lines such as he was the Picasso of oral sex
yes ladies and gentlemen sexy filthy boss
Oh, such a wabi-sabi.
Classic line.
Absolutely classic.
He was abstract or what?
No one can explain.
And the better part is it's a whole series.
He's got brothers.
What was I looking for?
Oh, I was looking for...
though i get so many like werewolves actually that's not so
surprising morning glory becomes more appealing to us when
the roles are reversed big bitty cow monster girl gf who
loves you for who you are yeah but that's like everything
that's like always the case i feel like hallmark adult
movies would be like that you think they would do that like
adult adult movies yeah my my book recommendations are
absolute trash because it's stuff like this and then agatha
christie no in between how all how all these books read by
gilbert godfrey yeah let's see morning glory milking farm
what's the second one called it's the one with the mothman
Okay, hold on.
Canberra Creek Creek Creek.
Wait, is this it?
No, no, no.
Wait, there's a different...
What is this one?
I need to see the author.
View full series.
Sweet berries!
Sweet berries is the second one.
It doesn't have nearly as tantalizing of a book title.
But this one...
Um...
Holy cow!
She gets with the mothman.
And the mothman, like, kind of sits in her window at first
and just stares at her.
And she's just like, oh, I got a mothman staring at me.
But he like...
She'll be like, Hey, mothman, you wanna come...
You wanna come do sexy time with me?
And he goes, click, click, click, click, click, click.
Like, he can speak, but instead he just clicks at me.
at her.
Reversed Emory Colette.
Yeah.
And then there's the classic line in this one of sweet
berries that is... Actually, I can't remember any really
classic lines from Morning Glory, Milk, and Harm.
But this one has...
I can't remember if he says it.
or she says it?
Essentially, it was of the variety of he is going to have
sexy time with me until I am boneless.
I think boneless was her line.
Okay, that makes sense.
Boneless!
What does that mean?!
Sometimes I really wonder what is going through these
authors' heads.
When they write these...
Like, it's actually just so...
Wow.
Not much.
Oh, it's so...
Boneless?
You couldn't just be like cliche and be like till I'm a
puddle.
Like that makes sense.
Like, you know, like, oh, I'm melted.
I'm a puddle.
But boneless?
There is also, I haven't, actually I haven't continued the
series.
But there is the Moonblooded Breeding Clinic.
I started that one.
There's some more.
I just haven't gotten it.
around to them they call them monster bait romances monster
bait romances yeah the what clinic you heard me you heard me
i've seen it under dark romance personally i'm just saying
how they categorize it i mean hey this author knows what
they like I think there was one that I listened to that was
just like in love with the lich.
There's an absolute market for this.
It's so funny because these are like housewives typically
listening to these, I imagine.
Or maybe everybody's just like me.
I don't know.
I read the reviews and people...
What is this?
Is this AI?
No, it doesn't look...
I can't tell.
I'm so stupid at being able to tell.
a romance of the mind sci-fi romance novel the tethered
resonance what is this one
what is this
this is really long never mind I don't want to read he looks
like an alien man is this Star Trek I haven't gotten into
aliens yet.
I haven't done aliens yet.
It's a real book talk trend.
Oh, really?
Book talk.
Oh, yeah, actually, there's one here that I've seen on book
talk.
I've been recommended this one.
A court of thorns and roses.
A lot of people have been like...
Yeah, you gotta get on that.
I was thinking this one, this would go in the direction of a
Columbo fanfic.
One more thing, Mrs. Wilson.
It's sloppy and not even good slop.
No, really?
The fantasy genre has been overrun by monster romance.
No, it's so bad.
No!
You know what?
We've fixed that.
He needs to finish Game of Thrones.
What's his name?
George R.R.
Martin.
He needs to finish Game of Thrones.
And then everything will be fixed.
Don't call them monsters.
They're just non-humans.
What?
When Monster Girl is like a total...
An absolute... Monster is a real category.
Monster is a real category.
Like...
Monster Girls and stuff.
Never gonna happen.
He's too busy playing Idol Master.
That was a joke.
Ha ha.
Fat chance.
Half-Life 3.
End of Game of Thrones.
Which will happen first?
His act does this mean anything to you?
George Raymond Romano Martin.
Okay.
Monster is a demeaning term.
Maybe to you, but I love monsters.
But we also don't...
Monsters, they also don't exist.
So no one...
Well, oh, sorry, sorry, Beasties.
As a monster girl myself, because I...
Ghosts are in the Monster Girl Encyclopedia.
I enjoy being called a monster girl.
Don't say that.
I'm gonna go write some ghost fanfics.
God, is Ghost Dojin or like some of my favorites though?
Okay, but ghosts are kind of basic.
You're basic!
What?
What is not basic to you?
At this point, any monster girl is basic.
Slime girls are basic.
Harpies are basic.
Lamias are basic.
But you know what?
Basic is not bad.
You know what's basic is water.
You know what?
Water you need it to live.
So, basic is good.
I don't want to hear it.
You know what channel you're on.
Do you know what channel you're on?
Water is actually pretty much pH neutral.
Shut up, nerd.
Shall we play some deadly permonition?
I probably should...
yapp less today because i fear that i will be streaming a
little less today because um hi i'm so sleepy from pack and
tomorrow i have a long day so basic ghost more like based
ghost yeah yeah all monster girls are good
not keep yapping
But I want to play game, too.
Today I scored the Miffy Starbucks collab and learned Miffy
is taller than Minto.
What?
Wait, did you get, like, the jumbo Miffy?
Plushy?
The yapping is my absolute favorite, though.
I'm glad you like it.
Honestly, I feel like this music is so, like, chill.
It makes me want to keep yapping.
I'm not going to lie.
Can you believe that, Zach?
The victim was completely boneless.
No!
Preachment I'm here for, I've subscribed to your newsletter,
I follow your teachings.
Thank you!
You guys know that I have good taste.
I have good opinions.
I am generally, generally correct.
And you can't handle that.
January, correct?
No!
Minto is always right.
On the topic of fine literature, how was the MGS2 dogen?
Did it have a plot line or what?
Oh!
I actually, so I just kind of skimmed through it.
I haven't read it yet, but I like definitely looked at the
pictures.
I will read it.
I will report back.
Like, I will actually, like, sit and read the Nihongo.
It's so funny because the Dojin that I posted about, I
posted it on the cover on Twitter.
It...
It has way less sexy time than you imagine.
It's so much of, like, riding...
in slutty poses.
And then sometimes snake.
I will report back.
That's still good.
Oh yeah, it's very good.
It's also so funny.
Minky likes pictures.
Yeah, I'm like a monkey.
Picture good.
You're reading the text in the Dojinji?
No, just kidding.
I do like the text in the Dojinji.
Why is today's stream like this?
What's going on?
What's happening?
Neuron activation.
What is...
It's the music making us feel a certain way, huh?
Hear that, Zach?
They're all freaks.
You did say you wanted it freaky today.
I want it freaky every day.
I'm the freakster.
If the day starts with a Y, I want it freaky.
Freak Monday, Freak Tuesday.
Ends with a Y.
Wait a second, I said starts with a Y, didn't I?
If the day ends with a Y, or in ye old Japan, if the day
ends with a Y, I want it freaky.
No, no, it starts with a Y.
No!
Yonday, Tuesday.
Wednesday!
No, yesterday.
Yesterday.
Yande.
I hate yandes.
Yandes.
I said, y'all.
Okay, where we ended off on deadly premonition?
Us.
TGIY.
Thank goodness it's Yard's day.
What if we added an extra day to the week?
Just randomly, because we're silly.
What if we were like, after in between Saturday and Sunday
is Yurds Day.
Vote for me and I will make it happen.
Yurdy Day!
Huge.
And it's a work day.
Ew, no!
No, I can't stop a y'all one and then.
Okay.
Um, we ended.
Deadly Premonition.
We last gathered everybody to the town hall or the
auditorium, whatever.
And we did this awesome presentation.
And then we talked to literally every single character that
could be the killer.
I'm not quite sure why it's necessarily somebody in the town
when there's like a super natural...
When this person has been like killing everywhere.
awkward dinner yeah we definitely have that awkward dinner
yeah we met the townspeople the community center that's the
word for it thank you yeah it was
something but I can't remember what we were to do now it
might have just been like go back and sleep or something.
We got hit on, too.
Previously during the investigation.
Oh, good.
These puppies are making me go to another town in the
boondocks again.
I didn't think you'd keep me waiting in the rain for so
long.
Welcome.
To breathe.
I'm going to there's definitely something in this town.
Go New York.
That's what everybody calls me.
Do you feel it, Zach?
Do you feel it, I blew?
Wait, this is not a good...
Previously, it didn't happen.
Speak up, Sheriff.
The audio balancing continues to be questionable.
I forgot how to play this game.
Okay, I'll remember.
We'll figure it out.
Oh, it's like pouring.
Oh, my goodness.
Holy cow.
Sorry.
I'm afraid of storms.
Okay, that's my...
gun no oh wait this is how i run okay good let's just go to
the yards and do i have my car can i take yours oh shoot i
got hit by a car maybe i can take one of these oh my drivers
controls thank you i need that yeah yeah um screenshot i
have my drivers controls handy.
We'll just go to the thing.
Last time I did like mega driving.
I don't necessarily want to do that again right now.
The poncho that keeps you alive.
Oh, it's really coming down.
Is there any car I can take?
Is this my car?
Why are you parked like that then?
Why does I have no car?
We're gonna have to run it.
Lightning, very, very frightening.
Silly little jump scare.
Turn it down just a tad.
Your car is...
Oh, wait, that's right.
We are...
Ah, the police station!
I forgot that they had cars in the back.
Thank goodness.
I watched The Wicked again recently.
Finally a day that's totally wicked, which free we couldn't
be happier.
Thank goodness.
This car has 67% gas.
Oh wait, should I move over a tad?
I'll go here.
But then you guys can't tell me when I need more gas.
Oh my god.
How does this number stalk me?
I am being haunted.
Wait.
Oh.
Oops.
Break.
Is there a reverse?
Okay.
We have nothing to talk about.
Where's my windshield wipers?
Oh, yeah.
Um, before we do this, now we've talked to everybody.
I saw some people saying, like, I should go get, like, a
sandwich.
I saw some people saying I should go do other things.
Is there anything I should...
Okay, we're at 66% gas now, so it's fine.
Is there anything I should do?
Wait, we can go get a sandwich.
It's, like, right there.
Watch this.
Oh, my bad.
Oh, but it's closed, I think.
What time is it?
You should follow your heart.
Because it's late, we just go back home.
Wait, can we go inside?
Is this the place?
Oh, no.
Sandwich is on the other side, really?
Yeah, it's closed.
Boo!
But, okay.
We'll do it tomorrow.
Yeah, it's pretty late.
Let's go follow our destination.
Accelerate.
Very, very, very incredible sounding music to me.
I don't remember what our destination is.
I think it might be the hotel.
Drift!
This is how Forza will go.
We're fine.
The entire soundtrack is good, but also makes me feel crazy.
No, I agree, I agree.
Don't whistle at me.
Oh, my blinkers still on.
I'm one of those types of people.
Oh my gosh.
It drives me crazy, though.
I'm really sensitive to, like, sounds, like, little ticking
sounds and stuff like that.
So...
Oh, you think I can go through here?
Wait, where are we?
Where are we?
Where is this place?
Wait, we can sleep here, can we?
But yeah, little like ticking sounds and things like that
kind of give to me.
Oh no, this is somebody's mansion.
The gate's covered with barbed wire.
No way through in here.
Oh, this must be, what's his name's house?
The crazy guy.
Okay, we'll just go through here.
The guy that does not speak.
I think the most nonsensical thing is the...
Oh, shit.
Is the map of this place, to be honest.
So says Mr. Stewart.
Where am I?
Oh, I made it back to the road.
Oh, awesome.
Okay, yeah, I think it's telling us to go back.
Why is it so sensitive today?
You okay, darling?
You a little sensitive?
When I'm sensitive, I get two bubble teas.
I get two of them.
Which was literally...
Yesterday.
day but also they had two new flavors and i wanted to try
both so you can't blame me
typewriter i'm a writer
what is happening york
the oreg army killer no okay then zach Let's go back over
our progress.
Yeah, this is a great time to recap.
First the victim.
Anna's death.
She was found hanging from a tree in the forest.
She was cut open with a knife from her chest down to her
stomach.
Is that similar?
That was the direct cause of death.
To the other cases that we've seen?
The strangulation marks and skull fracture were caused after
death.
That's strange.
Her tongue is also bit off and I found something inside her
mouth.
Do you remember what that was, Zach?
Uh...
Was it the pedal?
Uh, the red seed.
Right?
The red seed?
I'm getting quizzed!
We found the same red seed in her mouth.
Yeah.
According to Emily, it was raining when Anna was killed.
But traces of tears were still evident on her face.
Right.
Which means the perpetrator killed Anna under a roof in the
lumber mill.
your body into the woods after it stopped raining we found
numerous important pieces of evidence at the site of the
crime yes a total of four things knee prints in the grass a
wood chain metal dust a photo of a man with a tattoo on his
back yeah one other thing do you remember what that was that
one more thing it was the broken stiletto heel I remember
that Findage fetish restraints.
That's right.
A broken stiletto heel.
Aligning this with the other evidence suggests that two
people came into contact with Anna's body prior to it being
discovered by us.
Those being the perpetrator who killed Anna.
Almost distracted.
Never.
And this stiletto heel.
There is also the possibility that a third party carried
Anna to the list.
An accomplice.
That means we could be dealing with three people.
two or three people in any case miss stiletto heel may have
vital you can stop at one of two stores we need to find her
next we're just one we didn't use forensic methods but we're
still closing in on the criminal
have I forgotten anything ah of course what the marks on her
hand tell us that Anna was gripping something when she died
do you remember that Zack oh yeah What do you think she was
holding on to?
A gerbil.
A round object?
Wasn't it hair?
Am I crazy?
Sharp knife?
I love poop.
That's wrong, Zack.
Come on.
I'm sorry!
Answer again.
What do we suspect Ana was holding?
Round object.
That's right.
Come on, Zach.
Lock in.
Come on, idiot.
He marched on his hand to suggest a peace mark.
The man in the photo found in the woods had a tattoo of an
upside-down peace mark.
On the back.
On his back.
Yeah, yeah.
These two could well be related.
But we don't know for sure.
Next, the town folk.
Yeah, they're freaky.
A few are worthy of special attention.
Carol McClain, the singer and bar owner, she's Thomas' son.
sister.
Then there's Nick Kormack, the owner of the diner.
Both of them seem to be hiding something.
Hiding something.
There's Diane, the owner of the art gallery, who is out of
town.
Then we have problematic, old, rich, and eccentric Harry.
Both will be tough to Greg.
Uh-huh.
Well, we just have to go one by one.
Is that real?
I've been thinking.
one of the biggest rewards here is the fantastic food what
if we're enjoying food is cultural and yet it's also a bit
uncivilized it's interesting how good food motivates me to
work harder during investigations oh and on emily's back it
was strange to me hey don't take that the wrong way zach i
wasn't getting all excited or anything but it did make me
feel You're strange.
Nostalgic and sad almost.
It's starting to rain.
I think it's been raining, buddy.
I think it's been raining.
Oh my goodness.
What if we're so good at being a detective because we're
like psychopath that's like schizophrenic and Zach is in our
head?
Oh, what the?
What was that?
Pickles.
Oh, now It takes
a cycle to know another.
Exactly.
Hello?
Wait, was that a red plant?
Oh, we did it.
We cleared dinner.
Yippee!
Thank you for the cash.
I did not pay for dinner.
I instead stole from the register.
Oh yeah, I have to save often.
I have to remember that too.
Save often.
I like how he brought the whole dog house.
You don't want him getting wet.
Oh, we're back in here.
Hello, freaky twins.
Are you thirsty?
Yes.
Take a sippy everybody You must be very thirsty Oh no I have
dreams like this You only take milk with your coffee Coffee
with milk That's all But I only take coffee I mean milk
usually Oh
Stop judging us Yeah why does that make me thirsty
Oh Who are you?
My name is Becky.
Anna's friend.
Anna or Anna?
Some people say Anna.
What are you doing here?
My name is Becky.
Anna's friend?
She's a Pokemon.
Do your throat is quenched?
You must do what you must do.
Take a sip of coffee and go.
My name is Becky.
It's a strange Pokemon name.
Becky, Becky!
Huh?
My name is Becky.
Who opened that door?
Mysterious.
Okay.
We're on episode 2!
Oh my god!
It's lacked.
We could have probably done that last time.
Real quick, just to get to episode 2.
Whatever, that's fine.
Hold on.
Chocolate chip cookie!
That will quench my thirst.
Lollipop!
Thank you very much.
Much...
Nothing on TV.
Oh, my shows, my shows.
Is it gonna be something spooky scary in here?
Oh, uh...
Here we go.
This way we got the recap this time though, so it feels like
it worked out.
That's so true!
You're sure, you're right.
I stole from children and I'll do it again.
Oh, it's this kid again.
Oh, things are clipping in and out of existence.
Oh gosh, okay.
The game is actively breaking in real time.
Wait, that mannequin disappeared entirely.
If I go back here...
Oh, there they are.
Can I walk into it?
Okay.
But then when I disappear, I can walk through them.
How interesting.
That's me.
It's me as a baby.
Zach, do you remember?
Zach is me as a baby.
Is it or is it atmospheric?
We'll never know their vision.
Oh my god, he sleeps with the covers pulled all the way up
to his face.
Wait, he sleeps also with his eyes open.
I hate Mondays.
And yon days.
First thing out of the...
Bed!
It's directly related to us.
Sir, you have a smoking problem.
I don't know how on that.
But I do know I need some coffee.
George said he'd have someone pick us up in the parking lot.
Let's get some breakfast with Polly first.
Polly!
Wow, we got a lot of things going on around here.
Um, I think we're not stinkified yet.
Oh, our health say, uh, uh, recovered.
awesome.
Did that cost me money?
But it's an in-room phone!
I really need this photo of the bananas in my maid cafe as
well.
I would like to have it.
Do I need a shave, you think?
Nah.
Just finished my freak phantom-inspired rave fit for anime
and more this weekend.
Oh, she uplinked, so I gotta represent you.
Whoa, there.
Nuiko, thank you!
I can't wait to see you, please post pictures.
Did you need something?
Oh, it's this guy.
No, I was just passing by.
I didn't think anybody else was here other than Polly.
The door opening like that, just...
It surprised me, that's all.
Forest Kaysen, sapling salesman.
Oh, you can't see the doll.
I'm Kaysen.
Forest Kaysen.
Nice to meet you.
Travel a whole lot you see selling tree saplings just the
usual salesman doing the usual road trip Sometimes I feel I
don't know like a jolly old bumblebee spreading pollen FBI
special agent Francis York Morgan Call me New York.
I get it.
You're the special agent Scarface that everyone's yacking
about nice to meet you Francis No, I'd need a bigger scar to
live up to that.
I think you're I think his scar is pretty big I said it you
got it York you got it is this your first visit here then no
sir actually I've been coming here once or twice a year for
a while now I don't get much business here but it sure does
make a fine vacation I mean it's a gorgeous hotel at a
bargain price it's so relaxing in these parts too oh I just
love all the nature I feel so relaxed here oh the dog say hi
Lily!
Good boy!
Do you like dogs?
Hey, Willie.
How are you doing?
Let me point at you.
He's pretty smart too.
Oops.
Before I forget, let me give you this.
It's just a sample of what I sell.
Oh, thank you.
Pours it out onto the crows.
I've never seen a tree before.
So what brings the old FBI out here?
Wait, where did he get the second one?
what a murder actually wait what the perpetrator is still
out there try to stay really sounds like two miles away we
want to prevent it from happening again everybody sounds two
miles away oh it's a darn shame places like this used to be
the safest in America could I ask you something do you know
a lot about seeds I would hope so he's a sapling gardening
huh you don't look like a green I'm pretty much the only one
who can make those saplings sprout there's a trick to it
that can't really be passed on you know he's subject number
one secret of making a good smoked ham something like that
but you know once they sprout you don't need to do much you
can leave it be and why it'll turn into a big tree no matter
what happens kind of like those stocks that politicians buy
that just keep growing and growing well you just wait and
see this town is gonna love them are they invasive we were
just about to go take a morning stroll so i'll get going
good luck now with that case thanks oh gosh i wish oh my god
he has willy on his bike remember what the coffee said what
did it say forest casein f k this show has just begun
fk fk ule Wait, we can run to him?
Where was the...
Um...
Breakfast.
Please make up room.
Are these occupied?
Maybe it's the other way.
Okay, it's the other way.
FK in the coffee.
Yeah.
Polly!
Oh, she's there, but we're gonna get breakfast with her too.
FK in the coffee.
coffee my nose is so stuffed because my cafe is abandoned
but there's so much dust breakfast looks as good as
yesterday's I hope you enjoy it I will and thank you
sandwich I just meant casein actually oh good old mr.
casein did he give you a sapling as a matter of fact he did
I got my sapling don't tell me he gives one to everyone he
meets no no only to the people he feels comfortable with he
told me he must feel really comfortable with me he must is
there anyone he hasn't given a sapling to mustard okay I'll
just get it from the kitchen then no mustard has nothing to
do with it I was wondering if you know of anyone that Kaysen
didn't give a sapling to oh too much pepper I did think it
might be I'm sorry no Zack I forgot we'll never get anything
out of her will be what do you mean Kaysen he's hiding
something he's hiding something you think so too right Zack
oh yeah but no need to rush Polly all secrets are hidden
until they just turn the music down.
Audio balancing affecting a game.
Yeah, exactly.
The world exposes everything and causes chaos.
Just like this coffee.
What is it gonna say?
Mom.
Just like in the coffee.
Your mom in the coffee.
Oh yeah, I'm well rested, well fed.
Um, I guess now we go find Forest again.
Forest Kason.
Can we eat some more?
Fantastic coffee.
Yeah, what's our fortune for today?
Let's see.
I feel like this was supposed to be a serious game.
Turned into a parody later.
Unpredictability lies ahead today.
Lucky place.
An unpredictable life is a wonderful thing.
Cases may come flooding in like passengers at rush hour.
I don't think that we want that, though, right?
we're an FBI agent.
That means, like, lots of people are dying and things.
I assume.
That's what many cases includes, right?
It's like you don't want world peace.
Okay, York.
Another tick towards psychopath.
Where can I find Emma?
What is the maintenance on this place?
I do one day.
Hi.
Oh, hi.
Good morning, Mr. Morgan.
Oh, oh yeah, we can buy a new rainy stripe suit.
Wait, I kind of want it.
What's stabilizer?
Completely restores pulse rate.
Oh yeah.
And we can buy chocolate chip cookies.
I'm starting to get hungry too.
Why?
I always am not hungry until stream.
Oh, we gotta get a hot dog.
For 12 hours.
50 this is not your costco hot dog this is advanced 12.50
hot dog let's talk to her real quick hi oh no no i i tried
to go back okay hold on where i want to talk to her oh hi
thank you thank you talk there we go
Polly you look a little tired I'm fine well it's just that I
was cleaning up my room and so many memories came flooding
back to me memories oh my dear mr.
Morgan that's not the kind of question you should ask a lady
did he she think number 31 the beauty star what does this
mean wait what did he did she think that he said
memories Paulie is a precious piece of memorabilia somewhere
in the hotel find it and give it to her not to be rude but
memory deteriorates with age you might want to check her
room what wait where's her room upstairs?
No, there's nothing up here.
I forgot.
Precious mammaries.
What would her room if I were Polly, Miss Polly, Polly?
Behind reception?
You think so?
I just gotta find her room and break in.
But she's old.
She probably leaves it unlocked.
to nowhere.
What a fascinating place.
Oh, can we get a map of this place?
Oh, we can!
Okay.
What is... What are these?
What the hell does this mean?
Okay, this is...
What are these?
So these are doors, right?
points of interest yeah they're like doors where would her
room be this is kitchen i need a legend for this oh there
there there talk to diane god sorry this is oh down here
okay okay let's go Oh my god.
This way.
This hotel is massive, but also has like 10 rooms.
So it's kind of funny.
Sorry again.
Alright.
In there.
What's in here?
Oh god, it's so loud!
here does this go to oh the void on the kitchen maybe
potato oh oh oh no oh well good morning agent Morgan did you
sleep well morning George dreamland was quite nice you do
look well rested I was up practically all night doing
paperwork.
Thomas helped me out so I was able to go home and get some
sleep but not enough.
Uh-oh.
Diane got back into town late last night.
We should give her a visit.
Okay.
Which means going to the art gallery, correct?
She lives and works in the office there.
So it's the only place to find her.
Okay.
The gallery is open from 10 to 1700.
10 to 1700.
Time for some art appreciation.
I'm Smile?
Oh, I know what it reminds me of now.
It reminds me of, like, Gmod.
Anybody else feel that way?
Or are you like...
Agent Morgan, why do you want to go back in there?
If you don't intend to come with us, then we'll go on ahead.
No, no, no.
I'll go with you.
Thank you, and it's my birthday.
Kongu, happy birthday!
I'll give you also Metal Gear.
Happy birthday, congratulations!
Happy birthday, salutations!
Happy birthday, may your sky stay blue!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday congo!
The gallery is called Muses Gallery.
Muses?
The Muses were the nine daughters of the goddess of memory
in Greek mythology.
that's just like diane to name it that way is she that
intelligent oh my god oh maybe you'll see for yourself soon
enough what's wrong you see how emily reacted zach yeah i
sense that this diane is not popular among other women hi
brandon thank you you too i can't wait the gallery is on the
north side of town take the road along the lake and go north
she's not popular with the ladies i gotta meet her so
knowing greek mythology is now a crime according to women
according to diane wait oh bing bing okay uh let's keep the
big map open oh this is actually i can fish behind the okay
wait it's 3 000 yards away are you kidding me right now an
art gallery in such a small town yeah my prejudice to think
that it doesn't seem to fit green veil and every small town
has every right to enjoy art you're so right small towns
tend to be full of highly cultured people i am although i
can't say i've ever been to the gallery myself george what
about you are you into art actually yes i like going to the
gallery wow really george really i never knew that about you
for all this time emily please i'm just as cultured as
everyone else we are cultured people that you'd never going
too slow on the road is she the type that isn't very
appreciated by other women what do you mean exactly what it
sounds like Emily is she very attractive especially to the
opposite sex dang you're asking if she's sexy right is she
sexy she does always wear high heels and definitely it's uh
hard to explain but that doesn't make me biased okay she
just seems down on people she always has i just don't like
people like that that must be because sex appeal has no
effect on you now that's out of line i'm sorry emily i
didn't mean to poke fun at you uh that's out of line i also
appreciate sexy women it's like you're suggesting i'm the
total opposite of her is that it oh emily that's not what
anyone is suggesting let's just drop this conversation okay
oh you're just not as sexy as diane i'm so sorry shinobi
thank you so much for third.
Thank you.
You're just not nearly as sexy as her.
I'm so sorry.
Very smooth, the orc.
Okay, good.
We're catching it right as it opens.
Why are you guys all going so slow?
Oh, God.
Oh, I'm losing control.
Ah!
Sorry.
I think this is the right way.
Hold on.
Let me check my map.
No.
Whose house is this?
Where am I?
50 dead, 30 injured.
Says who?
I haven't hit anybody.
Where is this?
What is this place?
Oh.
Wait.
Oh, there's another house even further.
Am I lost?
No, I'm exploring.
I'm exploring.
The wide.
open roads.
Whoa, what's that?
I live here now.
What could it be?
I know if I get out of the car, though, they'll be like, oh,
we're going to go to Diane's without you.
It's shiny.
I want to have more conversation.
Actually...
Yeah, I'll just come back later.
I wonder if Diane has anything to say.
to do with the murder.
Diane moves on a whim and acts on impulse.
We don't want her leaving town, so shut up and let's get to
the gallery.
What are the, oh, we can raid their mailboxes?
Hmm.
I mean, I'm the FBI, I can do whatever I want.
I'm driving!
Oh, we gotta go this way.
Am I getting further?
No, we're getting closer.
I'm running low on gas, though.
Hopefully there's another car here.
Top tier driving.
The lines don't matter for me.
I'm FBI.
And I'm accelerating at a top rate.
Yeah, we're at 33% gas, so...
Hmm.
Extra long distance.
Yes, sir.
I will go the distance To the art gallery Managed by a sexy
woman I will admire her heels And her whole body I can go
the distance For any hot lady
Perfect Music's gallery Oh!
Whoa!
Looks more like an old mansion than an art gallery.
Diane liked the building so much she turned it into an art
gallery.
Uh, speak up, please!
And have the insights be done.
I'm gonna grab food right after this cuts in.
So she's rich.
She bought this place, didn't she?
Does that answer your question?
Oh, thank goodness.
Well, George, Emily, I want to talk with Diane alone.
Will you wait here for me?
Don't tell me you still don't trust us.
No, that's not it.
But this is very important to me.
I always make sure that I meet with the important ones,
one-on-one.
The important ones!
Otherwise, it's difficult to sense the subtle reactions of
the suspect.
I see.
He has, like, no light shine in his eyes.
Have you noticed that?
I'd appreciate your understanding.
He's complete dead.
But...
Go on, then.
You're not going to listen to us anyway.
Are you?
Soulless.
You're starting to understand me, George.
Well then, Zach.
Let's go and meet Lady Diane.
Lady Diane.
Yes, George.
You hear that, Zach?
We trained George.
We trained George like a good dog.
Fish.
I want to fish in this game.
I want to do that so bad.
What the...
Wow.
Where's the art?
Oh.
Hello!
No reply.
Let's take a look around then, Zach.
Is it gonna get spooky in here?
Okay.
Give me one second, everybody.
Wait, is this place gonna be like humongous and then...
Oh, man.
Resident Evil Mansion.
For real?
Okay, give me one second.
Okay, I'm back.
Yeah.
Time for some grub.
I wish I were a cutscene, though.
I can save here, but can I...
Do I have to pay for it?
What's a snack?
It's just a fried rice.
Thanks for the super tattoo, guys!
Thank you!
What does this say?
Reception?
Nobody to greet us.
Doesn't this gallery have any other employees?
That's, I think none of these places have other employees.
Oh, what's going on here?
Who are you?
Hello?
Why didn't you answer me when I called earlier?
Oh.
Olivia.
Hello, Olivia.
Do you like art?
You like jazz?
Yes.
Yes, I do.
well I mean I like trees what is mother nature if not art
okay ah but I see because these are all tree paintings do
you come here often then oh well no just sometimes I'm sorry
I really need to get back to the diner
Zack she was lying about something she said trees not
paintings of trees she actually hates trees there's tons of
trees outside
what if she just wants to see different kinds of trees like
what are you they're all like such the same trees outside
what if she wants to see different kinds of trees what if
she wants to thick trees and those trees two trees side by
side not a bad work of art but it looks kind of creepy what
do you make of it Zach
obviously not probably shouldn't try to get in here why
that's where she came from no trees at twilight a beautiful
painting of six trees bathed in a sunset glow
Olivia's Memo.
Oh.
Key to the gallery!
Why do you have that?
Huh.
This statue is...
Something, huh?
Okay, I see there's a red shiny over there.
Wait, so now can I go anywhere I want?
With a key?
No.
No?
This place looks like...
It's like a marble mansion.
It's kind of insane.
Crime aura.
Everything is trees!
Oh.
And memories.
Trees and trees and more trees.
What are the mannequins here for?
Hmm.
Oops, all trees.
Reasoning is quite valid, seeing that literally every
painting is a tree.
It's at least five meters tall.
Pretty big for an object dart.
Object?
Object dart.
Pointy branches, razor sharp leaves.
Good taste on the curator's part.
Greeting us with such a school and sharp setup, right, Zach?
What?
meters in America you have to understand this guy's FBI oh
good we needed the key anyway that works out what was that
it's so quiet in here places
we can't go wow oh my gosh this place is huge it's is it
actually all trees?
Tree and more trees.
Trees.
Yeah, it's an art gallery.
These are photographs, though, of trees.
Many, many, many, many, many, many, many trees.
Many, many, many, many, many, many trees.
It cost me a buck.
Oh, look at that.
What's the why can't you what probably shouldn't try okay oh
we're outside now surprisingly not a single tree uh can i
look inside hello anybody in here wait
What did we get?
What did we get, Zach?
Nothing.
Hmm.
I can't leave now.
Oh, that's the exit?
Oh.
Everything is trees.
It's all trees.
Oh, again.
Just kidding.
Uh, anybody here?
I will once again...
Nice!
I got some honor.
Yeah.
Not far...
Oh, it's in there.
I see a padlock door through the window.
I might be able to shoot the lock from here?
Okay.
Normal FBI agent behavior.
Why did we do that?
This is not our...
This place is humongous, though.
Sorry if I'm coughing a lot.
This place, my main cafe is so dusty for me.
Moving stuff around.
I'm still getting over being sick, too.
Girl in the woods.
Oh.
Trees?
I call this a painting.
A bit primitive with poor composition.
Hardly the work of a master.
But strangely though, it powerfully exudes a soft, warm
feeling.
On the back it says, Guardian of the Art Gallery in Fresh
Strokes.
So someone added that recently.
Guardian of the Art Gallery.
Wouldn't that be Diane?
And why is this painting here?
Who are you to criticize?
FBI special agent York deems responsible for multi-car
collision causing thousands of damage.
In the same assembly, you said, I'm FBI.
I can do what I want.
Call me York.
That's what everyone calls me.
That's actually what would happen.
Don't.
Keep dry.
What's in here?
Nothing.
You have all this.
Nobody utilizes their space efficiently in this game.
I think that's where we came from, right?
Maybe.
Actually, I'm not sure.
I'm lost.
In the sauce, for real.
Well, we do need to go this way.
Aha!
What's in here?
Truly though!
There's more!
I like how he takes like five steps at a time.
Is it more trees?
Where are we?
I don't think this is part of the gallery.
Um...
Where are we going?
What the hell?
Take some honor.
Not for honor.
Ah.
This, an automatically sliding storage room.
Oh, it looks like paintings are stored inside.
Oh!
I thought this was like the, like, you know, the, what's it
called?
Like, their power, the just.
Okay, thank you very much.
Thank you.
What do you have in here?
I don't even know why I'm doing this.
I'm just being a little...
Take it.
Take some smoked salmon.
I thought they said there would be paintings in here.
Hmm.
Alright.
And then the one that's most important.
Oh.
Oh!
What's that?
Observe.
Butterflies frolicking.
Large tree and red butterflies.
It almost looks like it's burning.
Is that it?
That's all I gotta do?
Okay.
That was the basement, I guess.
I wonder, you know how like some games kind of want you?
I feel like, well, okay, hold on, I'm getting ahead of
myself.
Some games really want you to go in like sequential, like,
okay, you go to the place that, you know, You're supposed to
go talk to this person, so you go talk to them first and
then you can explore and things like that.
But I don't think that's this type of game.
I think this game really just wants you to do whatever the
hell you...
Whatever the heck you are, you know?
Cool.
Alright.
Hello.
I'll need to unlock this to enter the office.
The password is a three-digit number.
Turn on and off?
Did I get a three-digit number?
What?
Zach, something is still missing.
Oh, yeah.
We need more clues.
The memo!
Wait, how do I look at it?
My item list.
Thank you guys for reminding me about that.
Oh.
Olivia.
Sunset at tree.
Wait, trees at sunset.
Red leaves dancing red butterflies trees at sunset was six
red leaves was that the Sun's oh no that's trees at sunset
red leaves dancing red butterflies was one because it was
one tree I
thought I looked at all of them hmm
hold on let's go back just to make sure.
I thought I looked at all of them.
Hold on.
I could also, you know what?
We could just, like, run through all the numbers.
We could just, you know...
This was called Tree at Sunset, right?
Yeah, trees at Twilight.
Close enough.
Six trees.
The butterfly one was one tree.
Maybe there's something over on this side that I...
Oh.
That I didn't quite catch yet?
We could brute force it.
I want to see the tree, though.
I want to see the tree.
Maybe.
Depending on how big this place is.
Wait, can I get down that way?
How do I get over there?
Impossible.
Yeah, it could be a super awesome tree.
Oh, wait.
Oh, no, I'm running.
I thought I saw, like, a little shiny.
Huh?
We definitely went everywhere, no?
Unless it's, like, in here.
And I just didn't see it.
The locked door that I saw, we got that guardian.
That guardian painting.
I wonder if we could try and go back in here.
No, okay.
Wait?
That looks big and fancy.
No?
Really?
Oh!
Ow!
Painting used to be displayed here.
The title plate reads, Red Butterflies Frolicing.
The painting is nowhere to be seen.
Okay.
What about here?
Hmm, no.
What is the point?
Yeah, that butterfly one was the one we got in the storage.
So, I did miss that, but we just found it early.
And then that was the guardian, which didn't have, like, a
treat.
Okay, we're going to just...
Where else could it be?
I feel like I'm missing an...
I feel like I've explored everything, but the game is like,
nah, you missed the area, dummy dumb.
Like maybe it's in there somewhere.
All right, what was it?
I don't remember, wait.
Wait, one second.
Wait.
Zach, something is still missing.
Wait, what's it?
We need more clues.
Six, one, six, wait.
Oh, it didn't matter.
Six, five, one.
Okay, okay, okay.
Or not five, sorry.
Six, blank one.
I mean, we'll try five.
Can you imagine?
Zach, something is still missing.
We need more clues.
Where could the last one be, though?
The next cutscene might have a crash because it's cursed in
all the ports.
Okay, thank you.
6, 1, 1.
We are...
Zach, something is still missing.
We need more clues.
Ugh.
6, 2, 1.
Zach, something is still missing.
We need more clues.
It must simply be 6, 7, 1.
I'll do it to Zach satisfy your curiosity but there's no way
it could be six seven one okay thank god Zach something is
still missing we need more clues it's eight zero zero eight
what was I on six four oh
Yippee okay we'll go do a quick save.
I'll leave them.
That's so far.
I did just save.
It's fine though.
It's just right here.
It's far and also not far at the same time.
How am I a cheater?
I couldn't find it.
I don't know where it is.
If anybody who knows this game wants to tell me where the
painting is,
I thought I checked every room.
I thought I did.
The scariest tree of all is trigonometry.
What is that?
I don't know what those mean!
It's green outside.
I'm scared.
What happens?
I've never had a game crash on like the switch.
Like I said, there's no point in you having this.
I can put it to far better use.
I'm taking it with me, okay?
That's fine by me then, as you wish.
whoa
the FBI agent right just wait a moment please I'll be right
with you absolute cinema this game
so there's no way you could have been at the scene of the
crime that's right I was drinking at the bar with Nick until
early morning I'm sure if you ask him about it he'll say the
same well what if Nick is awesome though The perp.
Damn, Diana is hot.
I'll be sure to do that.
One other thing.
That argument with Carol just now.
She's always like that.
She thinks of me as an enemy.
Always bickering at what I say.
Is there any reason for that?
She hates trees.
Perhaps because someone she liked ended up with me in my
bed.
Whoa!
That would explain it, yes.
If I may be so bold, who was the lucky man?
Oh, I sleep with anyone I wish.
Anyone I prefer to sleep with.
Can Yorkie get lucky?
I guess she had her eye on one of them, but I don't know who
it was exactly.
I could sleep with you, if you like.
I'm flattered by your offer, but I don't think that would be
appropriate.
You're exactly the kind of woman that a man in my charge
should never get involved with.
Isn't that a shame, darling?
Whoa.
Wait, but like...
York, this could be our lucky day!
But Zach would be watching the whole time.
It's so awkward.
Frank, right now you are not a suspect.
But both Zach and I are certainly feeling shaky about you.
Don't ask about Zach.
If you want to remain in the clear, just watch yourself from
now on.
Oh, you don't know, do you?
Artists and art lovers, we love a good thrill.
Oh.
Thank you for your help.
What does that mean?
I have nothing further to ask you at the moment.
Goodbye.
Not the dog!
We cleared the gallery.
That was strange as per usual of this game.
What did we get out of that?
Um...
What did we learn?
I had a chat with Diane.
She said she was at the bar drinking with Nick at the time
of the murder.
We need to confirm her story.
Let's talk to Nick at the diner.
Very well, Agent Morgan.
I have to head back to the department and clear up some
paperwork.
Go with Emily to the A&G diner.
Okay then.
I'll show you the way.
The diner's open from 9 to 2100.
Do people actually say 2100 and stuff?
second Diane is the key to this case I have a feeling she
will lead us right to the criminal why did we suspect that I
thought FK was in her coffee speaking of oh my god looks
like the show has just begun and it has an all-star cast all
star star studded where can I sleep wait it's showing I can
sleep around here one moment one moment emily oh dang it she
won't let me collect my agent on her why do you want to go
back there because someone dropped their cash that's nothing
i need her to direct me i like to have the conversations
with them okay then let's go it must be diane's bud yeah
baby and there's card back there too!
Wait, I want to look at the window.
Wait!
Emily, you're making me miss out on all the fun!
I'll never forgive you, Emily.
Emily is evil.
Evil, Emily.
It's nothing, there's nothing.
Alright, let's go.
Is this the car we're taking?
Alright, Emily, show me to the place.
Wait, is she gonna be sitting next to me?
That's kind of fun.
Instead of... Oh, yeah!
Emily, do you know a man named Forest Kaysen?
Kaysen?
Yes, I know him.
The sapling salesman, right?
He always uses strange comparisons when he talks.
I'd like to know more about him.
What does he do when he comes to town?
He's a salesman, so I guess he sells things?
Maybe he comes on vacation?
We haven't seen many tourists recently, but he comes pretty
often.
Well, now that you mention it, He seems quite friendly with
the Ingrams, with Isaac and Isaiah.
Are those the twins?
Maybe you should ask them about Casey.
Okay, I will.
I just finished my fried rice.
All right, buckle up, buttercup.
Did I just run to a car?
My bad.
We're heading?
Wait, how do I...
Accelerate?
Wait, why can't I move?
Emily, this car is defective.
I think we need to get out.
We need to find a new one.
Is there something you want to check out?
Well, either way, it doesn't matter.
I can see you won't be rushed.
Wait!
Oh!
I'm gonna go ahead, okay?
Okay!
That would be fine.
Yeah, never mind.
The diner is open from 9 to 2100.
We can now go to the bed.
Don't keep me waiting too long, okay?
I would never.
Let's go get my money.
These trees are crazy.
Do trees like this actually exist?
Like the really...
Like those ones?
The one that looks like...
It's on fire?
Wow!
That's 90...
Oh, we can sleep in her shed.
Okay.
What's this?
Onion!
I got onion.
Onion.
Everybody spell it.
Spell it in the chat right now.
Onion.
That's me.
That is you.
Onion.
Nice.
Destruction of property.
I'm FBI.
What's in here?
Onion.
An extra 30 bucks.
That'll buy us one slice of pizza.
You guys don't understand.
Oh, another onion.
All right.
Until 2100.
The only people I see talking like that are like...
Are like...
Like a military.
person like you're give me drop and give me 20 until 2100
wait a second i don't remember this room
it's called military time after all it is well i call it 24
hour time there's like 12 hour time then 24 hour time to me
at least Observation.
I love that I get money for being a creep.
Emily, you'll never believe what I found.
Anything over here?
A poor parking job.
This car is blocking the way we'd be able to get through if
we can move it somehow.
A.M.
PM split is kind of awkward.
I get it, I get it, it's awkward, but also I get using it,
you know, like, I like, I see the, the value of both.
AM, PM, and 24 hour time.
No way around the car.
You have to understand that our poor, our poor York can only
lift his legs so much, okay?
You have to understand.
Alright, where are we going?
Like this way?
I miss having Emily with me.
Both is best.
Yeah.
NPCs have their own routines and schedules and meet up with
each other in this game, so you're encouraged to explore and
be a creep.
That's so crazy!
Oh, I missed my chance to talk!
That's okay.
They'll come back.
This car is kind of crazy.
This car is really speedy.
Get out of the way!
I can't control it!
It just goes fast!
I'm going almost 60!
I can't control it!
The diner.
Yeah, we're going to the diner.
We're gonna get ourselves a sandwich.
Yay!
Get out of the way!
Oh my god!
Okay, we're fine.
Okay, we're technically still getting there.
Can I take the... Oh.
Coffee and cherry pie.
Ooh, my game is lagging.
I saw blue.
I'm getting out of the car.
Oh, I missed the A!
It's okay, we'll get it when I...
I want some pie now too.
Zach, is there something here that you want to check out?
We are supposed to meet Emily at the diner, but that's fine.
Do whatever you have to.
Yeah, open.
Why do you have bullets?
Why do you have bullets in your mailbox?
I have the FBI.
I love cherry pie.
Oh, whoops, not observe.
You can't keep this, you should clean your inventory.
No!
Maybe I need to eat or something.
Everybody gets a free bullet in this town.
You just gotta put it in your, you know, everybody's mailing
out bullets.
Or something.
As FBI, I need double the space.
I did press Y, but it still wouldn't let me.
I was pressing it.
In the 4s of the game, can you use turn signals?
I think I saw, like, a Hollow Life girl she was playing it,
and she said that she could...
She had no turn signals.
Don't you think there are a lot of good-looking women in
this town?
If the fact that this game...
grew up in.
This game has turn signals and knock one dozen is kind of
crazy.
Elizabeth Scott Moore.
She couldn't be royalty with a name like that.
She said she used to deliver newspapers on a new gig.
Hey!
She was like an actress from a B movie, wasn't she?
Bleached blonde hair, too much makeup, clothes showed off
her cleavage, and that mole by her mouth.
Oh!
Say, Zach, were you with me back now?
You know, that mole was made with makeup, right?
We happen to be on the same bus once i saw her drawing it on
with makeup no isn't surprised i guess what do you mean
words across that she would go that far to create that image
do you remember that movie we went to go see that day i'll
give you a hint oh there's a waterfall it was the force in a
popular series and was produced by manahem golan's canon
films figured it out sack no i think it opened it call it
your homework until next time wait what do you mean oops i'm
turning on everything i'm thing.
Wait, what?
I think I go this way.
I think?
You're...
We're gonna have not a single good working car left in this
town.
Toy Story 4.
Oh.
I see.
Okay.
That makes sense.
Toy Story 4.
The toys are 4 again.
They're at, they're...
It's a work in progress.
What time is it?
Oh, it's 11.
Okay, good.
Can I cut through?
Oops.
That should be a park.
There's so many trees.
I wonder if you can make the Minto Pinto in 4s of 6?
Is there Pinto in the... probably not, right?
Sandwich coming right up!
Emily!
Oh.
Emily, were you waiting outside for me?
Should I have gone inside and started the 20 questions?
Well, that would have been fine with me.
Shall we get something to eat then?
A pie!
Someone should teach you how to be more considerate.
Cherry pie!
And now you want something to eat?
I thought we were going to question Nick.
We are, we are.
Wait, who was Nick again?
We met this guy.
He was at the bar.
Allegedly.
Welcome, Mr. Agent.
Hi, Olivia.
Let me have your special for today.
And some fresh coffee.
Uh.
Our special today is turkey.
A turkey and cranious beverage.
Oh, I was going to say just turkey.
That's good.
Perfect.
Emily, you eat something, too.
It'll be on the FBI.
Wow.
Okay, then.
I'll go all out.
I'll have the T-bone steak.
Dang!
I usually can't order it because it's a little too
expensive.
Let's go, Emily.
Olivia is laughing at your poverty.
She's still going.
What the heck is...
What is this guy doing here?
He goes to diners?
This is Olivia Cormac.
I am here.
for mr.
Stewart's lunch if it is ready I thank you a bunch yes of
course just a moment and throw in a mixed bag of munchkins
one turkey strawberry jam and cereal sandwich cereal
sandwich sounds like the sinners sandwich self-infected
punishment to atone for past because of the cereal wait why
does it sound bad mr.
Francis York Morgan you should try this wonderful lunch it's
more than a delicious tasty crunch so says mr.
Stewart no that's fine I've just ordered I feel like turkey
and like a strawberry goes well no cuz it's kind of like a
turkey and cranberry sauce mr.
Francis York Morgan mr.
Francis York Morgan that is mr.
Stewart's order is delicious I should mention and mr.
Nick Kormack is a genius for creating this perfection so
says mr.
Stewart still I have a hunch I might not like it I need the
deadly premonition like collab cafe so I can try the
sandwich I need it mr.
Francis York Morgan he sounds more and more impatient is
always a sign of bad FBI agents.
Mr. Francis York Morgan.
Harry, you're right.
I'll give it a try.
He just wants to eat the same foods as you.
Oh, wow.
That's not what I expected.
Is it good?
It must be good.
I can't believe it.
This is fantastic.
It's really...
good Olivia I'm sorry I'll have what Harry's had
draws a gape they cannot believe what they are seeing what
they are hearing now cut that cabbage nice and thin Nick and
Diane they hardly make the perfect couple do they I don't
want to be a sandwich idiot I don't want to be To be honest,
I don't pay attention to these things.
Not into local gossip?
Well, when I moved here, I was still in high school, and I
kept wearing the same wild clothes from my school in
Seattle.
I was young back then.
And before I knew it, there were rumors all over the school.
She'll screw anyone.
That's what they said.
Totally unfounded, of course.
Anyway, after that, I just sort of chose not to really trust
gossip.
Why don't you like Diane?
Let's go, girl.
I get where you're coming from.
I used to dress like a hardcore punk rocker when I was in
high school.
You?
A punk rocker?
Nobody took my side.
Even when I had good grades.
People rejected me.
Just because of what I wore.
I was young back then, too.
Oh my god.
Even still, I just don't see you.
Oh my god, she's really cracking up here.
It's been a while since she's cracked up.
Sorry if you hear noises, by the way.
I'm trying to fix my mic.
Ooh, get caught.
Okay, back to work.
Get caught up.
Let's talk to Nick.
He's yucking it up.
Nice.
Oh.
Hello.
Hello, Kason.
Are dogs allowed here?
he's mad how are you doing boy hey willy wait where are you
going what happened what was that sound like he was chomping
he got me casein willy just ran off with some bones i was
carrying as i can't really go he's still holding on to the
plant that's not good willy loves bones he's a dog and
carrying bones why won't you turn and look at me Throwing a
blonde in a bikini into a boy's locker room.
It's almost like you were asking for trouble.
My bones!
You're just gonna have to forget about your bones.
I better run after him now.
I'll see you later.
Forget about them.
If I gave up that easily, then I wouldn't be a good federal
agent.
What, Isaac?
We're going to have to search his house, Zach.
I love that I can move this, but...
Let's get back those precious bones.
I cannot walk.
Snack for Willy!
Oh my god, our side quest.
let's look at our side quest list actually what is on our
list right there's 50 of them we have 11 and one other right
31 yeah
oh my gosh York is now boneless it was foretold as as the
prophecy foretold.
Coffee!
Oh, that's fine.
I want $200 for the coffee.
Emily.
This place is lively, unlike the hotel's dining room.
Not as noisy as the city,
Olivia.
I was wondering, if you could tell me what the A and G
stands for.
Oh yeah, I was curious too.
Apple and gravy!
Oh my god, why does she talk like that?
My husband has always been proud of his special gravy made
with applesauce.
Wait, that sounds amazing though.
Look at her face.
My husband's always been proud of his special gravy made
with applesauce.
So when we were setting this place up, we used it in the
name.
Nick's father suggested that we put something we're proud of
in the name apples and gravy well that's one burning
question answered I would like to ask you a little bit about
Nick too oh my god please she sounds terrible it's like
actually peaking a little is okay like what oh nothing major
just a few things about him and Diane.
Oh!
I think that was...
We hit a sore spot, for sure.
Olivia does not want to talk about...
She's about...
him and Diane.
Wait, we do have a beard?
I need to shave, don't I?
Diane claimed to be drinking with Nick on the day of the
murder.
I wonder what Olivia was doing then.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Nick.
FBI.
I'm working here.
You can't just stroll into a chef's kitchen.
Then perhaps you would give me your permission to enter.
Yes, chef?
No.
Get the hell out of here.
What kind of chef works in a...
Zach, everyone has their own sanctuary.
In like...
Let's leave him in his.
In their sweater like that.
Wait, why can't I talk to Nick?
I need to.
Hey, I'm working here.
No way.
Chef's kitchen.
Do I have to come back and see him and lie?
Maybe perhaps you would give me your permission to enter.
No, get the hell out of here.
Zach, everyone has their own sanctuaries.
Let's leave him in his.
Okay.
Oh, talk at the window.
You're so right.
The store owner looks quite friendly.
friendly.
He's not.
He's a real jerk, actually.
What's up?
Could you tell us what you were doing the night Anna was
killed?
I think it's really funny that that was a cutscene, but this
isn't.
I was at the bar with Diane.
What did you two talk about?
Nick.
Rembrandt and Turner.
Is that a problem?
He looks real friendly.
The arm movements are crazy.
No, no problem.
If you think Diane did it, you're wrong.
No, that's not it.
Sorry.
Oh, so it's me hereafter, isn't it?
You're wrong again.
So much for the FBI, huh?
This isn't the case.
That isn't the case either, Nick.
I think there's something both of you are hiding.
An affair!
You can tell when people are hiding something by their
reactions.
We really do have a beard.
Oh my gosh.
I gotta shave.
Eye, tongue and hand movements.
Sweat, dry lips, neck angles and such.
My lips are dry because I need to drink more water.
You're also dehydrated.
Don't forget your dream.
Sometimes I have dreams about drinking water when I'm so
thirsty.
You guys ever have that too?
This man made you the sinner sandwich and you're accusing
him.
What's my tongue movement like?
Guys, I'm gonna tell a lie and you can tell me if I'm lying
or not.
I hate Koharu.
Could you tell?
I love Koharu.
How could you?
Could you tell the difference?
The first time I was doing 25 tongue flips per second, but
the second time I was only doing 15.
I'm working here.
If you aren't ordering anything, get out.
Mix signals.
Okay.
Well, he still doesn't want to talk to me because he's a
jerk.
I've already told you what I could tell you Don't make me
say the same thing twice I'm Nick I love Oh there is
something back there He says I'm Nick and I love paintings
The menu
Oh nice I also will save La la la Voice.
Gasp.
Okay.
Um.
Well, Emily, what do I do now?
This guy doesn't want to talk to me.
Nick and Diane's stories match up.
It isn't hard evidence, but it certainly supports her alibi.
Ah, but the two of them could be in cahoots.
That's what I said!
I think we need to talk to Olivia again, Zach.
Yeah.
There's something I'd like to confirm with you, Olivia, if
that's okay.
Well, so long as it doesn't take too long.
First, what were you and Nick doing on the night of the
murder?
I was here in the diner.
Nick said he was going to the bar for a couple of drinks.
Yeah?
Does he go to the bar often, leaving you to hold up the
fort?
Yeah.
yes he says he enjoys the conversation with Diane I thought
then who was doing the cooking night do the three of you
ever go drinking together well you see I'm really not into
art but you were and your husband is well versed in the arts
then I take it oh yes looking at art and talking about it is
his way of relaxing wait actually people just aren't what
they scene what like a certain she only likes trees punk
rock 10 years ago oh my god i get over it absolutely right
emily but you can be an art lover and a liar oh you're an
art lover and a liar you just said that you aren't
interested in art that's right and why'd i catch you earlier
so how come i bumped into you at the art gallery yeah didn't
seem like nick brought you there reminds me of the phrase my
mom says a lover and a licker I like trees about our dog
that's why I went there surely you'd be better off in the
forest rather than an art gallery then I think you went to
the gallery not to see trees but to see Diane right you
don't want to answer or perhaps this isn't the right place
to ask meet me in the backyard you can get there from the
parking lot i'll wait for you there for an hour after we
close oh i have to wait till you close time to investigate
the town a little bit they close at 2100 should we get
something to drink and wait sure
just chain smoke outside we could or we could fish we got
some bait legend worm high quality beef that is not cooked
ultra rare life is beautiful agent york what do we do now i
want to hear what olivia has to say Let's kill time until
the diner closes.
Okay, then I'm going to make a trip back to the department.
I'll see you in the backyard later.
Okay, sounds good.
Isn't it?
See you later then.
Oh.
What's up, Zach?
I presume she wants to tell us something about Nick and
Diane.
Let's hope it's not just something for the gossip cards.
Mmm.
I like how he was just like, why you're not into art?
Then why were you at the art gallery?
Why didn't you...
Um...
Why...
Why didn't you just go outside to see trees, idiot?
Like...
Like she can't enjoy...
All the paintings were trees!
Every single painting was a tree.
Every single picture was a tree.
And yet, she's not allowed to go to the art gallery.
Oh!
Oh god, I can hear her munching her toast.
You hear that?
that.
Oh, Kaysen.
And his dog is still here.
I gotta go to his house and take his, take my bones.
God, she's a loud eater.
I can hear her through the window.
One second.
My cat messed up my window.
Speaking of windows.
I want, I want something sweet.
Actually, I do need more water.
I'll grab it in a second.
So can I get in here now or do I have to wait?
Oh, I could.
What happened to your bones for no reason?
My bones!
Gosh, it's so bright.
Oh, God.
It's so bright.
I want a cookie pie or something.
Actually, Vic.
got me some some because we did on the Densetsu channel we
did a like a British snacks test tasting and I also did I
also brought some American snacks and so some of the British
ones were so good and Vicky got me some so I've been like
kind of like just one chocolate a day but I haven't had my
chocolate today like I I just have one little piece.
Where else can we go?
They close at 20.
It's 11.30?
No, time didn't pass at all in this place.
Yeah, the arrows, the arrows.
That's what I'm talking about.
They're so good.
They're so stinking good.
They're like...
It's like chocolate that is like so light and fluffy.
Hmm.
Go sleep in the shower.
Jack.
I want to go look around, though.
There was one place that looked like a theater.
I can't remember if it's this place over here.
It says it's a...
What is this place?
Oh, this is the PlayStation, isn't it?
I think?
But it doesn't...
It looks like a restaurant.
Or...
This is the PlayStation, right?
Am I crazy?
Hold on.
Do we have Arrow in the States?
I'm not sure.
I think I've seen it before.
I just never tried it.
But I'm hooked now.
Oh, I didn't mean to grab that.
Emily.
Ooh, someone just left the TV on.
Kind of creepy.
I only got something because of my friend in Canada.
They can get in the States.
just need to be a place that does imported candies.
Ask Doki to send you arrow from Canada.
Yeah?
I guess I could.
You can use LR buttons to switch windows while peeping.
Oh, really?
Wait, we'll try again.
I'm gonna go grab the arrow.
And maybe one other snack.
I'm so snacky today.
Sorry.
It says building a bubblier future.
And she also gave me, what is this?
Crunchy.
Cadbury Crunchy.
L.
R.
Oh!
It worked!
I pressed R and I went to a different window.
L though for some reason doesn't.
Only R.
Interesting.
I forgot my...
I forgot my water.
Crunchy.
Not crunchy?
No crunchy.
Oh, multi-pack bar.
I almost read the whole thing.
Well, now I'm going to try...
I'm going to try crunchy.
Crunchy.
It is.
The chocolate bar.
Oh!
Woo!
Whoa.
Whoa!
That's good.
It's almost like...
What do you call it?
Butterfingers, but like crunchy.
Yeah, that was crunchy.
Like that lived up to the name.
The name does it justice.
Is there...
Okay, guys.
Is there anything I should try doing?
Whoops.
If not, I'm just gonna probably smoke until dawn.
Fishing!
Where can we go fishing at?
Play darts.
Oh, yeah, I needed to get that...
the gun for it, right?
George Sidequist gets you fast travel.
I don't know.
I don't... I'm not unlocked that, I think.
To recap, the movie was the fourth sequel of a series that
started in 1978.
That's right, Zack.
It was Superman 4.
Superman 4?
Lex Luthor was back.
It was played by Gene Hagman.
needed a must for all us fans.
Alfred, I don't remember much more about it, no.
I'm sure there was more trivia about it.
Still forget four.
Richard Donner directing one and two.
Now those two were great movies.
Christopher Reeve really shined as Superman.
Actually, Zach, I've got a confession to make.
What?
I must not to tell anyone because I'd be really embarrassed.
Okay.
I actually like the first two Superman movies more than the
first two Star Wars movies.
I think John Williams did a better job with the theme song
for Superman.
But whenever I try to hum it, it always turns into the Star
Wars song somewhere along the way.
Oh, I have songs like that, though.
I know.
So, Zach, which Richard Donner felt do you like the best?
No need to hurry.
Take some time and think it over.
Okay.
I'm trying to see if there's a place for me to go fishing
around here, but I think everything is...
I think fishing is unfortunately quite far away.
What is that pink block, though?
There's nothing here.
Nothing here.
Hmm.
Yeah, I guess we'll just go...
Oh, I can't see.
Oops.
It's the house.
Oh.
Okay.
Yeah.
We'll just, uh, go over there and...
Oh, that was a phone booth.
We'll just go and smoke.
Eh, I'll go and smoke.
Get out of the car.
Can look for the bones.
I don't know where his house is.
That's okay, though.
In the Director's Cup version of the game, the pink block is
a house you can sleep in.
How?
Why?
Wait, if I do it...
Oops, I didn't mean to pull it out again.
If I go in there right now, I wonder, it'll automatically,
like, go until night.
I want to hear what Olivia has to say.
Oh, okay, okay.
Let's kill time until the diner closes.
Okay, I'm going to have my single arrow of the day.
Whoa, it's so bright.
Oh, my gosh.
Please, my eyes!
Oh!
No, I want to go in.
Come
on, do it.
Your FBI, you can do anything.
FBI, open up.
Use.
La la la.
21 is 9 p.m.
Yes.
That's right.
We just stood here for like nine hours of our day smoking.
Smoking for literally nine hours is kind of insane.
Wait, what just happened?
It didn't become...
21 o'clock though I'm stinky I feel sleepy I should rest or
have a coffee oh I'm smelly because I've been oh wait what's
happening here does he have my bones in here Zach I'm glad I
don't need a warrant to search a dog house yeah
stinky and sleepy I can't wait we could go to that house oh
I got my Bon!
Looks like we've picked up a little bonus, too.
We'll have to give Willy something to make up for this
another time.
A root beer?
What's the dog need that for?
Oh, completed!
So he only took one from me?
Maybe we can go to that house, the pink one.
I think this is the director's cut, no?
And then we can go, um, take a nap.
Because it's, we still have 40 minutes.
We just gotta run there.
It's not?
Wait, what do you mean it's not the director's cut?
I thought I said it was.
Oh, there's some cash money there, though.
La la la la la la la.
There it is.
Oh, oh my.
I didn't even realize.
This one, no?
No, this is different.
Wait, there really is nothing there.
Huh.
Mysterious pink shape.
Unless it's that house?
Oh, wait.
No, we can't go in.
How mysterious.
Hmm.
So mysterious.
Why?
That's so annoying, though.
Hmm.
Do what I dare you.
No way.
He just...
We found our killer!
Someone!
Find that guy!
Run his license plate!
Penalty for being rescued.
Oh!
No way.
They took money from me!
Wait, I'm all the way...
Wait, are you kidding me right now?
I'm all the way at the hospital?
Wait a second.
Wait, I missed the time!
No.
No, what day is it?
Fiona, what day is it?
How's the investigation coming along?
Making progress slowly but surely.
asking um you know we don't we don't usually do this but
just let me know if you need any vials of sedatives or
tranquilizers to help with the investigation you know won't
i need a prescription i have permission to give you access
to the ones that i don't that don't need prescriptions if it
will help with the case that is oh don't worry though
they're all properly prepared i didn't mix them myself for
anything don't you trust me take a look for yourself then
they're all legitimate medicines first aid kit oh wow
okay well now we know we can buy stuff here I guess I
thought it was like a oh my god I'm smelly and sad and tired
no what day why it's Christmas day no wait when did I last
say
I think I saved.
Wait, there's like no car around here, is there?
Wait, what's the purple?
What is that?
I smell so bad.
What is this?
Oh, it's here.
I'm silly.
Oh, no, no.
done with this.
Oh, it's the retry dungeon.
No, thank you.
I don't have a car.
Yes, I do.
Okay, if I reload...
Title...
I think I saved in the diner.
I'm almost positive I did.
I'm like, almost positive.
Previously during the investigation f k f k never fails ah
the perpetrator bid off honest tom jack potzack shame but
our old time all american sightseeing torches came to an end
when purple fog covers our town we'll all wander in hell i
forget it so says mr stewart so said mr stewart well there's
an old story oh can i skip this it's fine this is a fairy
tale to me George is always so quiet.
Oh, wait, George!
Maybe we can do his side quest.
I wonder.
Maybe we can actually do a side quest.
I guess I'm on board like, oh, yeah.
Okay.
Awesome.
I think maybe...
Did I talk to him already?
I've already told you I can tell you.
Okay.
All right.
Now we just got to talk to Olivia and she'll be like, meet
me outside for our secret meeting.
All right.
Come on, come on.
I'm going to skip it, though.
Uh, I think you went.
Oh, meet me in the backyard.
Okay.
Now we'll go to the police station.
They close at 2100.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shut up.
Shut up, Emily.
Yeah.
Because if we can get the fast travel, that would be huge.
We need to load to mission two for Georgia side quest.
Load to mission two.
What does that mean?
Oh yeah, we gotta get our bone.
That's right.
We gotta get our bone again.
Let's get our bone.
So we can also get a root beer.
Alright, now we're not even smelly anymore.
Everything is good.
Here, I'll skip this one too.
We just did it.
the laggy the laggy items looks like we've picked up a
little bonus too yippee okay root beer but this one's not
laggy you have an item for one of georgia side quests but
not the fast travel oh no i see that's what you mean well
we'll see we'll see what happens
Where was it anyway?
Over here, I see it.
Hey, get on your side of the road, buddy.
Gosh.
Toachak!
Nice.
Why does everybody want me to go to the milk barn?
It's like so many people telling me to go to the milk barn.
The only thing is I don't want to get too far.
far away because I get lost and also I don't want to like
only I don't want to fill the whole day with side quests is
my other issue
hello George oh Thomas wait Thomas do you have a quest I
have something to admit I'm a certified minke lover and
you're a certified ass eater thank you either like Tyson's
ass hello you're going to see Nick today right then you'll
have lunch at the diner I can make something if you like yes
please I'll have it ready for you in a jiffy Thomas have you
ever eaten Emily's cooking what hey what exactly are you
asking yeah what's this just wondering what you thought of
her cooking that's all you know perhaps an unbiased opinion
of one who is himself a fantastic chef so how about it have
you eaten her cooking i have just once and how was it really
that's not an easy question honesty is the best policy how
can i say this cut it out agent york he's pleading the fifth
he has the right to remain silent don't try and force him to
say something pop jokes right to an attorney
in a court of law.
Ah, they're so funny.
Let's just go to Emily's cooking go, okay?
I can't do that, George.
I wanna know.
I guess it's just one curiosity.
So tell me, Thomas.
Well, for lack of a better word, let's just say...
Why is the hot dog...
It's Amazon style cooking.
Ah, that was well said.
Why is the hot dog in the coffee?
The silent laughter.
The hot dog in the coffee.
What is going on?
Oh, you were lacking words, were you?
Yes, sir.
All right.
What's the weather?
A fine, clear day, a perfect day to have a walk.
Thank you.
Oh.
If I were George, where would I be?
Hmm.
Zach, did you see that?
A floating hot dog in the coffee.
This place definitely surprises me every day.
Hmm.
On his throne, his porcelain throne?
Or...
Wait, does he have an office?
Is he in the jail?
Is there anybody down here?
I thought Emily was supposed to be here too.
Oh yeah, nobody's, everybody lied to me.
Nobody, people just don't want to hang out with me.
They hate me.
Oh, you guys said you were working at the police station.
Oh, this is the shooty.
Hot dog in the coffee.
Now available at dogs and dinos.
We're in the store.
Absolutely.
You can check them out.
I wish I could zoom out.
Oh my gosh, can I go to...
Oh, because I'm downstairs.
Oh my gosh.
I need to get Nick the top.
Okay, our side mission.
Oh, okay, okay.
Where the heck am I?
Oh, I'm still in here.
I don't have a key for any of these either.
They're free to go, sir.
Today's your lucky day.
Eany, meany, my NMO.
And you get chosen for Death Row.
Yippee!
Uh, is this how it came out?
Okay.
The sound effects are so good.
I'm glad you think so.
I'm glad you think they're really good.
Oh, wait.
in there.
But everybody else is missing.
He's so tiny in this huge room.
He's so itty-bitty.
What's a small man like you doing inside?
Oh, he gets smaller.
He gets tinier and tinier.
He's just shrinking, wasting away.
Yeah, I love that you can zoom in the map, but you cannot
zoom out in the map it's a really really awesome feature
okay i used to use the item up here and pick up sound tone
as my ringtone in 2010 i've thought about it i was like oh
my god i like don't get well i get phone calls every day
because my numbers like on some spam list but i don't have
my ringer on and i'm like man but what if i set my phone to
like the codec you know that's so fun Okay, hold on.
We're going to the map.
Map.
Who is this?
Sally Graham.
This is Anna's house.
What is that?
Brian's house.
Why is it shaped like that?
And this is Thomas?
Yeah.
Where is everybody?
Okay.
I get so many spam calls.
I think I'm thinking of changing my number.
I get so many.
Like, it's that bad.
We could go down.
Wait, is that a king?
Look, he's got a little trophy.
If we just go down the street from where, literally, where
we are, we just go down green street.
We just go down green street.
break a fish.
But I don't have a fishing rod or anything.
Do I need one?
I imagine I probably...
Another boat.
Imagine I probably do.
That's the community center.
Oh my gosh, my coughing won't stop.
Who's that?
Lily is on the bridge.
For some reason.
And then that's Busby Polly.
Diane is also at the hotel!
Now why is that?
How curious.
How curious indeed.
The farm.
Oh no, where's the milk bard?
Am I- I'm lost?
Oh wait, what if we go down a little bit more?
Pete Otherworld, no thank you.
This is the...
Wait, am I lost?
Yes, but also...
What's this?
Copes Tunnel?
This place is way too big.
That's the lumber mill.
Oh, that's right.
Try West.
Am I going west?
I don't even know how to get over here, though.
Wherever I am.
Who is it?
Oh, Brian the Insomniac!
We met that guy, yeah.
Kind of messed up.
The General Lysander.
What is that, though?
What is...
The milk barn!
And there's a dog!
Willie!
Wait!
I thought Forrest was at the cafe.
Now he's at the milk barn?
Roaming...
Oh, I can't remember how to pronounce her name.
Emily's house.
Okay, hold on.
Now let's figure out...
Who are these guys?
Heaven and hell...
Oh, that's right.
Jack the Raging...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
This is not so bad.
We just go down...
This one.
Whatever the hell that is.
Millie Way Avenue?
Milky Way Avenue?
Okay.
Mailby Way?
Minky way?
Okay.
We go.
Alright.
We'll try the milk barn.
Why not?
I
think...
Where'd it go?
Wait, where'd it go?
Wait.
I literally lost it.
It's not here on the map at all.
Wait, where did it go?
Huh?
wait where did it go to recap the movie was the fourth
sequel in a series that started in 1978 that's right Zack it
was Superman 4 the quest for peace Lex Luther was back it
was played by Gene Hagman that alone made it a must for all
us fans I don't remember much more about it though I'm sure
there was more trivia about it still forget four Richard
Donner directing one and two Now, those two were great
movies.
Maybe this way?
Christopher Reed really shined as Superman.
Actually, Zach, I've got a confession.
Wait, what is that?
Oh, that's a racing thing.
I promise not to tell anyone because I'd be really
embarrassed.
I actually like the first two Superman movies.
Yeah, we heard you the first time.
I think John Williams did a better job with the theme song
for Superman.
But whenever I try to hum it, it always turns into the Star
Wars song somewhere along the way.
I know it's strange, Zach.
I know.
So, Zach, Richard Donner film do you like the best you need
to hurry take some time and take it over guys I'm lost
do you see where I need to go I'm so lost
reindeer street I'm so lost
huh I'm looking at the man.
Drive up the road by the diner.
U-turn, U-turn!
Official business!
Oh wow, I don't know how I managed to avoid all that.
Waste.
Road by the diner.
Over here.
Let's see where we go.
This is like driving while holding your phone up for the
map.
I don't think I'm going the right way.
No.
I'm not going the right way, I think.
No!
We need to find Milky Way!
Okay.
No.
Hmm.
Hold on.
Minkee Way!
Yeah.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna pull up the map.
Okay.
I wish I could zoom out!
This damn game.
Wait, no.
It was...
Okay, hold on.
I hate that it rotates.
It's all rotated and now I don't know anything.
Wait!
Wait, there was the lady standing in the middle of the road,
not you.
Wait a second.
No, wait, Lily Ingram is now here.
Wait, no, she was in the middle of the road.
Wait, where the hell are we?
That's the diner.
Wait, she was in the middle of the road, I know.
Hi, boss, when you're done finding Minky Way, can we stop at
McDonald's?
What?
Do you think I have time for McDonald's?
There are people dead, buffed Ogapy.
People are dying.
Wait, this is the Milky Way.
So she was, like, in the middle of the street here.
Now she's...
Okay.
So where are we?
Okay, so we just turn left, right, where I'm at, and we just
follow the road.
Okay, and then that will lead us to the milk barn.
Okay.
Whoopsie.
We're good.
Okay.
Okay, we're back in it, baby.
Just keep going.
Am I going?
Yes?
Here?
No, wait.
Maybe I have to keep going.
Okay.
Can we get those people McDonald's too?
Ghosts like McDonald's, yeah?
Wait, I see it, the Milky Way!
Maybe we do.
Maybe we don't.
Some of us might like it.
A little bit.
Oh, to be Minto's passenger with a thrill?
You could be my little passenger princess!
I'll take you all over.
I can show you the world.
Shining, shimmering, splendid Tell me, princess, when did
you last let your heart decide?
I can open your mind Take you wonder by wonder Over skyways
and under On a magic carpet ride A whole new world.
Hey!
Where are we?
Are we there yet?
No, I see it on the map.
A new fantastic point of view.
No one to tell us no where to go.
Say we're only driving.
The milk bar.
Yeah.
George!
You're here.
What are you doing at the bar?
You're on duty.
It's a tough job.
Police and FBI work.
Really tough jobs.
This is all a dream come true.
Don't get me wrong, but maybe our heart shouldn't decide to
swerve in the oncoming.
I have a self-driving car.
You wouldn't understand.
Oh.
He's distracted.
Gricotch.
Whoa.
Where's the milk at?
A help yourself snacks corner.
They even made handmade cookies, though.
It seems they aren't that popular.
And handmade loaves of...
Oh.
I just robbed this guy.
Delicious cookie
Delicious cookie But it's bananas
If this game were made Today If this game were released
today People would say this is AI Business gift Flavors
Newly New Zealand, Spanish, Spanish.
Sugar-free.
Bread?
Cherry boy.
How do we know she's not a suspect?
How to raise vegetables to be able to easily make?
This place loves bananas, I'm telling you.
It reads, employees only.
We have no reason to go barging in.
I have every reason I am FBI.
Do you want some basabada?
Or some USA fruit.
How about...
How about moe dog food?
Or use?
Oh, USB series!
It's the family size, that's why it's so large.
Delicious cookie and cocoa gum.
There's a huge block of ice inside.
The fridge itself is an old design.
Cool drink.
Not a drink in sight.
What is this?
Sparkling water, maybe?
The most ever.
Chugging the gigabyte cereal for real.
USB cereal.
Breakfast...
Breakfast 2.
The sequel.
More whole grain.
Fresh, fresh.
Oh, you got tea and...
Anna...
Wait.
Anna Jemima?
Isn't it supposed to be Aunt Jemima?
Aren't those pancakes?
Pancake mix?
something.
Am I crazy?
Breakfast 2 Electric Boogaloo.
Tealy.
Oh, we found it!
Breakfast 1!
We found Breakfast 1!
In the OG game, all the grocery items were branded, but they
didn't pay for the licenses.
You can tell with a lot of these.
Not gonna lie.
Like, Max Wall House.
Cottonel.
Yeah, Cottonel is a brand no I love breakfast one and
breakfast two these are great I can't read that
rock-and-roll night delicious cookie and it's a melon
Kason I need to talk to you you so now they needed a new
sheriff's assistant during the one of the candidates proved
his stupidity over and over again.
It went something like this.
What's one plus one?
Uh, 11?
So what day comes after Sunday?
Yon day.
Eh, the day after Sunday?
This went on for a full 20 questions.
Oh, I said yon.
Oh, Did he just start a conversation from the middle or did
I miss something?
No, I don't.
I think in the middle, maybe.
The sheriff totally exasperated by this awesome melonhead
resorted to irony for his final question.
Who killed JFK?
I don't know, came the reply.
And you can find out for homework, okay?
The idiot candidate was so happy to hear this, he ran to
tell his old mother.
Mom, you know what?
sheriff likes me I got the job he put me right on a murder
case York did you hear that quite a funny story no I think
we have a slightly different sense of humor well that's a
shame you're wasting a good chance to laugh with a joke like
that one talking to Keith makes me loose loose sense of time
oh
we have a toolbox here
Delicious cookie.
Can I pet the dog?
You can't pet the dog.
Bad game.
I'm...
What was that?
Okay guys, we might need to smoke until 9pm.
Nemi!
Thank you so much for the redirect!
Kumbakua!
Hello naplings!
Hello!
I'm continuing this fever dream of a game, deadly
premonition!
Oh, I should show you guys.
Would you like to see the milk barn?
Rest in glitches, thanks for the get-tune!
CC, thank you!
I guess you have to thank you look you guys come look at the
wonders you can buy at the store thank you thank you gopo
thank you take up and you and thank you you can get not only
breakfast one but the sequel coming to a theater near you
breakfast two more whole grain please.
You can get apple.
That's pretty normal though, right?
And you can get how to raise vegetables to be able to easily
make.
Oh, wait, I didn't read this one.
If it is an idea of cooking, cultivation of vegetables,
recommended cooking ingredients, appetite, and health, okay,
anything.
What about USA fruit?
Was that New Zealand in a box?
It was New Zealand and also Spanish Spanish and then we have
flavors flavors flavors could be a good business gift I am
delicious cookie do not it's it is it's like that show is it
cake but it's actually is it cookie and the banana is cookie
flavors is favorite?
I really like flavors a lot.
Yes, so please, you can also enjoy some USB cereal.
I also really like USA fruit.
Because what does that mean?
Wait, what's up there?
Bees.
Interesting bees.
And honey cooking.
Very interesting.
Everything is so interesting.
America.
America taste.
It tastes like freedom.
Wow.
This is what an alien thinks human crochet shop looks like.
Actually, though.
And no burgers?
This is...
My
game crashed.
Do I have to do all that again?
I didn't save.
I didn't.
It didn't save.
Honestly, it wasn't that long ago.
We'll just smoke until we have to continue our current
quest.
Micmac, thank you so much for the five gifted.
I never had a Switch game die on me like that.
must be stinky we must be i think i have to go through the
whole diner scene again though hold on yeah i mostly just
ran around i didn't actually do anything gameplay wise so is
this guy always been here okay let's talk to olivia we're
gonna have a little cut scene uh so we're basically we have
to ask olivia why they close at 21 why her husband hanging
out with this lady at the bar at the night of the murders
but we have to wait until they're closed so uh and the game
has an in-game clock of it oh my god we gotta get my bones
back yeah it's the dog stole my bones
Zach I'm glad I don't need a warrant I don't think you need
a warrant to search a dog house, but this is on that
guy's...
You need a warrant to search someone's car, no?
The music is great.
Okay, we got that money for the side mission.
I'm...
There is... Actually, hold on.
There's a phone on the other side.
Oh, right over here.
We are going to save again.
Just in case.
no way it's on the other side of the wall i'm stupid wait no
there's one over here
right here right on the other side of this wall where is it
oh no oh we're here okay okay oh right we're right across
from the police station life is beautiful is never going to
unclog from our heads as it meant we're doomed aren't we
This is our life.
It is our life.
And life is beautiful, isn't it?
I'm going to smoke in the middle of the road and see if I
get hit again.
All right.
Let's pass the time, baby.
We have to wait until 9 p.m.
us when we're stinky, I wonder.
Tau tau tau tau tau tau tau tau tau tau tau tau tau tau tau
tau tau tau tau tau tau tau tau tau tau tau tau tau tau tau
tau tau Tau tau tau tau tauau tau taau…
Wait!
Oh yeah, okay.
It forces us to stop smoking.
Not for...
Oh, we could eat.
I feel sleepy.
We could eat.
Maybe Thomas has some food for us.
Oh it's closed.
Wait, but the diner is still open.
It's still open for another 40 minutes.
this game has a heart rate monitor well it's kind of like
your stamina so it's a little less of a heart rate monitor
like for myself save again yeah we can save inside I'll just
shower eventually who cares if I smell who cares they say it
makes me a worst FBI officer but I don't believe that how
are you here again you were an enigma how how did you do the
stinky minky all right nice
you hey york the food here is the best isn't it don't you
agree i'm going to go up another notch in my belt before too
long no matter how much i watch my diet i always pile it
back on in this town he's wiping he's he's swatting the
flies away a bear before hibernation that was investigative
info Olivia can you feed me I'm so hungry
meet me in the backyard the flies wait we're gonna get flies
in our cutscene there for an hour after we close up yeah
overalls don't need belts I was thinking the same thing wait
did we not open this oh there's nothing in there no Wait,
Nick, please serve me.
I'm starving.
Oh my god.
Yeah, we got the menu card.
That's right.
You can eat the onion.
Oh, let's get even more stink.
Become ultimate stinky.
Oh my gosh.
And you guys don't realize.
Look at my sleep and my food.
I am so tired.
and so hungry.
Yikes.
Um, I don't think inside buildings your time passes at all.
But...
Hmm, what can we do to pass the time?
We can go fishing!
Wait.
Where was it?
Please don't crash.
Having a smoke than eating some raw onion.
We are literally the smelliest guy alive right now.
We are the smelliest man alive.
I think it was down this road.
Let's go check it out.
We still have a half hour.
It's almost time, but like, it's gonna be a...
Oh, whoops.
I forgot we had a boost.
Boost mode.
So I think it's right down...
Here.
I think?
Hat dog!
Double checking the wiki as I remember being able to
interact with the dog a long time ago.
If you connect all the bones before completing the quest,
it's you an infinite revolver!
The movie was the fourth sequel of a series that started in
1978.
That's right, Zack.
It was Superman.
Oh, we already listened to this one again.
Okay.
Surely this is the way to fish.
Fish, fish, fish, fish, fish.
Yes, I found it.
Oh, that was my headlights.
Oh, sorry, I forgot how to break.
I forgot how to break for a second.
My bad.
Oh, I could think of it.
about was the fish.
Alright, how do we fish?
We could just capture one of the flies flowing and around
me.
You know?
Oh, those are birds!
We got some birds even.
Alright.
Let's do it.
Let's go fishing.
Wait, do I have to go down there?
Oh, probably.
I thought I was from up here.
Wait, no!
No, please!
I don't know how to use my legs!
York!
Just kidding.
Unless.
It hit.
Yeah, I thought I was gonna go...
Wait.
I found it!
Oh, the fish are flying!
What is that?
A beaver?
Oh, I think it's a stick.
I was like, what's this river on?
Believe me, I know a good fishing spot when I see one.
Trust my special agent instincts.
Alright, let's do it then.
No.
Do I need a fishing rod?
It's only been like two minutes since I last decided I
wanted to go fishing.
Use your hands, York.
Your special agent hands.
You can buy it at one of the stores.
Well definitely don't go to the milk barn for it.
All they have is breakfast one and two.
But they don't even have the best one.
Breakfast 3.
That was the most popular of the trilogy.
It broke the curse of like a sequel can never be the better
movie.
Everybody knows that Breakfast 3 is the best.
Are you ready for Breck Slow?
No, that's literally what they say.
That's what they say in the movie.
They're like, I'm going too breakfast, too furious.
But once this is all over, I'm ready.
ready to go.
Rek slow.
That's literally his famous line.
I went to see every Richard Donner movie on the day they
premiered.
Every single one.
Goonies.
I skipped breakfast today because I didn't think it could
get any better.
It does!
It has to be Ladyhawk.
That was back in 1985.
Same year as Goonies.
Goonies!
Both Rutger Howard and Michelle Fiverr really shine in that
one.
But more than anything, it's the story setting up.
But don't watch the new remake, The Gooners.
It's not good.
What a curse.
Don't you think so, Zack?
They can only be together at dusk.
Zack, we'll finish our chat later.
We'll finish our chat later.
Let's take a walk around here.
Uh oh, I'm having another arrow.
Thank you so much for the tangeter!
All right.
We have 15 minutes in-game time.
Maybe we're close enough that.
It'll just let us, you know.
Oh, wait.
There was cash there.
Let me out.
You think we can all agree breakfast revelations never
happen.
I don't even know what you're talking about.
Alright.
Let's go save one last time because of the time that it is.
I'm sorry that I have to keep saving over and over again.
I got it.
I got too comfy with the game not crashing at all.
And then suddenly it betrayed me.
It betrayed me.
There's only three breakfast movies.
Everybody say it together with me.
There's only three Breakfast Movies.
Only three Breakfast Movies.
Wait, there's more stuff in there.
Come on, Nick.
Let me explore.
Oh.
One thing about this game is you have to be very deliberate
with your button presses.
Or else it farts at you, apparently.
Like, I tried to press left.
press it hard enough my goodness excuse you it's because i'm
smelly isn't it you're like what's another smell what's
another smell working here you can't just stroll okay can't
stroll into your kitchen your sanctuary sanctuary sanctuary
let me out of here i'm stinky in the kitchen Okay, now he
has a good reason to kick me out, but...
You know...
I'm not unsanitary, I just smell bad.
I still wash my hands!
You can smell my hands!
They're clean!
Not an ounce of dirt!
I might have stuck my hands in the river to try and catch
that fish, but...
That's running water!
We are in a clean state!
What should I do?
Let's smoke another cigarette.
Let's smoke another cigarette until it's time.
Okay, it's time.
Yippee!
Kason, what are you doing?
Kason's car.
Christian, the big red nursery.
Kendall not optional, apparently.
Wait, I want to see him get in the car.
Oh yeah, good boy.
Dude, I dare you.
They're working on a reboot movie just titled BFST.
I ain't gonna fly in the next anime convention.
Oh, oh, we're sleepy.
We'll get some Z's, we'll catch some Z's after this.
Oh, another cigarette?
My man.
How many is that today?
She's gonna notice my fly.
She's like, is there something different about you, York?
Well, then Olivia talked to me.
Come on, Olivia.
I've been waiting for hours, please.
She's like trying to hold her breath, you can tell.
In the beginning, Nick only went to the gallery during the
day.
But he went so often at some point he became friendly with
Diane.
Uh-huh.
They started going out drinking together, and now he doesn't
come home until early morning.
In the beginning.
They were only drinking in my ass.
He blames me for not being able to talk about Turner and
Rembrandt.
Not!
Of course I can't, can I?
So what can I say?
What do you mean?
You could always learn about R.
What are you talking about?
I mean, I couldn't take it anymore.
So I followed him.
Yeah?
He did go to the bar to start with.
Diane was there too.
But the real problem is where they go to next.
Yeah.
So, I waited outside the bar to see where they might go.
And they eventually left the bar and headed for the art
gallery.
But it was... it was already early morning, but it was still
dark.
Just before going inside, Diane turned around.
Did she knew that she was going to follow?
It should have been too dark for me.
But I swear, her eyes looked right at me.
She seemed to flash for a moment.
She's an alien.
I was so rattled that I left and went home.
The next day, Anna was found dead.
I didn't know what to do.
Oh my god.
Is she gonna cry in our arms?
Oh, she's gonna cry in Emily's arms.
Maybe she would cry in our arms if we didn't stink.
I went to the gallery to talk with Diane about it, to
confront her.
But once I was there, I couldn't find the courage to go
through it.
No, Olivia, no!
Then I saw you there, and I just felt I had to go home.
No.
Nick has been seeing Diane every night.
Every night?
He just left for tonight, too.
Don't know what to do.
does anyone smell onions York we need to take Nick in for
questioning no not yet this alone isn't enough he's just a
cheater not a murderer Emily wait what's happening this is
Emily agent York is with me too I've just received word from
Thomas at the sheriff's department something has happened at
Becky's house uh oh he was called in by Quinn but he wasn't
making any sense we have no further details.
I've sent Thomas over there.
Can you go back him up?
Oh, yeah.
Yes, sir.
One other thing.
Yes?
It sounded like he said raincoat killer.
This may well be related to the murder case.
Take all due precautions.
You know we haven't.
No.
It couldn't be.
Nick?
Why would it be Nick?
Oh, Blake, no.
Is this a new song, by the way?
What did he do?
Uh-oh.
Olivia, it's raining.
Calm down.
Emily, take your Olivia.
I'm heading over to bed.
I was thinking earlier that we hadn't had any combat this
time.
She lives in a big house over by the lake.
Big house over by the lake.
Yeah, a free shower?
Serious.
Damn it, Zack.
We may have screwed up during the investigation.
Oh,
I think I got a raise.
$9,000, baby.
Why is he staring at me like that?
I'm in a hurry, Zach.
I have a feeling about this.
Becky's house is by the lake.
By the lake.
How far is that?
Wait, how do I reverse again?
Oh, my bad.
I don't think I can be like...
What's his name?
My wipers are this?
Nope.
Wipers.
Okay.
this.
3,000 yards away, okay.
Hey, hey!
Oh my god, world's slowest driver over here.
Alright, we can figure out how to get here.
Easy peasy, probably.
Subtitle spoilers?
No!
Uh-oh.
Back it up, back it up.
We gotta go to a different way.
I am going to call it soon because it is Densetsu meeting
time shortly.
Oh, but I feel like we've been making good progress.
Maybe this way.
Yeah, that should be good.
Say hi to the girlies for us.
I will.
Tell the girls we say hi.
yeah we're trying to like figure out when we can do our next
collab because my my schedule is like all screwy right now
there's something i'm doing next week don't worry i backed
up just in time oh oops oh i have no gas and no no damage on
my car right now but um there's something i'm doing next
week that i can't quite talk about yet but i'll be able to
talk about it soonish but it's pretty cool i think you guys
will be like, whoa, that's awesome, Minky.
I'm excited.
Wait, where's that go?
Where did that go?
I don't think it goes where I needed to go.
Whoa, that's awesome, Minky.
Thanks!
Wait, do I need to sleep or anything?
I mean, I could I guess it's fine.
It doesn't seem to be affecting my driving or anything,
so...
Whoop!
Am I going the right way?
Yeah.
You're driving very calm.
Wait, we can boost, I forgot.
Wee-wee-wee-wee-wee.
It's the police!
Get out of the way!
Pull over!
Don't you know the rules?
The rules of the road!
Totally not affecting your driving.
No, I'm just looking at chat.
Honestly, like, it doesn't even affect me.
Oh, I forgot that I'm not on the...
I'm boosted, but not on the acceleration.
I just... I'm a little distracted, but I don't think it
affects so much.
The bullies...
Becky!
I'll do anything for Thomas though
Wait, Becky was in my dream That's right At this point,
sleep deprivation would be safe Wait
Wait Tell me Her name is Becky My name is Becky I am Becky
That's just a Pokemon Why is it?
The elephant Did you see the raincoat killer?
No No, he said something else.
Actually, I think.
Thank you, Thomas.
Could you see Nick here?
Oh, Becky.
When I got there, he's already like this.
You should be here soon.
Call George and tell him to get right.
We now hear him.
I'm going inside.
I'm going in.
Once they both get here, he follows George's order.
Okay.
Yes.
But Agent York, isn't it dangerous to go in there alone?
Take this.
Zach is with me.
Who is Zach?
What if this Jack did driving and not the graduation of
Spaghetti Chime is the reason for this?
Jack, let me smoke my first.
The flies!
I need to clear my head so I can take everything in.
Who is Spaghetti Chime?
What is that?
Are we about to do a spooky time?
I'm gonna have to start the next stream with the spooky time
though.
Whoa!
What is going on in here?
I
had a nasty feeling about this.
Let's hope it's not a big welcoming party.
Oh no!
Wait, I didn't get to save.
Oh shoot.
That's a save right there, right?
Wait...
Oh!
Oh no!
I did the wrong button.
It's one of these again.
Yeah!
Okay, we're fine.
Uh, uh, uh...
Runs away.
Tootaloo!
Why is it so slow?
Okay, I get it.
There's nothing inside.
Open?
But there's something in there.
Dramatic tension.
Take.
We got a first aid kit medium.
What is my health?
Oh, my health is full.
Okay.
That's great.
I really need a save point, though.
Please.
Please, please, a save point.
Oh.
Yippee!
Okay, good.
Oh, okay, we're in a safe room.
And we can sleep.
Safe room?
Safe room.
What's happening?
Zach, that's a strange coincidence.
What?
Red velvet.
Whoa.
Just like the place where honor was murdered.
Yeah, I could change my suit.
Breakfast to money.
Don't forget to add flavors.
Yes!
Thank you for super time!
I got it.
Thank you.
Oh, I'm profiling.
We're gathering clues, everybody.
Legs?
Stop.
I swear, I won't tell anyone about Anna.
Becky, what do you know?
She's getting strangled!
Becky!
He's thinking real hard about that.
I don't think there really was much there, though, no?
Am I crazy to this?
Too much noise.
We're still missing a vital piece of the puzzle.
Someone get these flies out of my phone.
I can't see correctly.
These flies in my face.
Alright, what we're gonna do is we're gonna, we're gonna
take a little nap.
Oh, we're hungry too.
We'll do a long sleep.
It doesn't matter the time because whatever.
Oh, we're like starving now though.
I better get something to eat soon, Zack.
Alright, we'll take a, we'll take a, we'll get a snack.
With Zack.
What do we have?
That's like a concern.
Oh, a little bit of hunger.
A small amount of hunger.
Oh, a moderate amount.
We can...
Oh, the smoked salmon!
Nice.
Hot dog is also moderate.
We'll do the green tomato.
You ate a lot.
Okay, that should be good.
It's not from last week.
Well, this is not Metal Gear.
Things do not go bad, right?
And then we change our suit.
Oh, wait.
Change of suit is here.
We're stinking no more.
Workaholic.
Looks brand new.
Well, I like the crimson one.
We change, yeah.
We don't even need this...
You guys, you don't...
It's very dirty.
You don't need to wash yourself at all.
All you have to do is stand in the rain for a bit and then
change your clothes.
And that's all you gotta do.
It'll take hours for it to get cleaned.
Cherry pie!
I could have used that to eat.
That's wonderful life advice.
You should never take life advice from a ghost.
Yay!
Alright guys, we will go through the spooky dungeon house.
It can't be that big, it's just a house.
But we will do that next time!
Thank you so much for joining me again today for deadly
premonition.
It's very spooky and scary and all sorts of things.
Thank you for the stream, though.
Thank you!
Thank you for being here.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Can we ask for some afterlife tips?
Maybe when you're older.
Ask again when you're older.
You're not as dead as me, so I can't tell you.
Maybe when you're dead, or I'll let you know.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
It's okay, I tell that to all the little baby humans.
Okie dokie!
Otomito!
Thank you guys so, so much!
See you and I see you next.
Yes?
Hmm.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, everybody!
See you later!
Thank you!
Otomito!
Otomito, otomito, otomito!
Bye bye!
Bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye thank you bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye